welcome to park gym 3 presented by grip6
and a huge welcome to my new co-host
miss andrea bottas and welcome to your
version
i'm so excited i'm so excited it's my
first time
commentating and i'm really happy to be
doing it with anna today
what was it meant to be it was meant to
be i just hope that the same thing will
not happen when i had cutest cinderella
as my dream co-host and then my power
went out so cross fingers
that just because we have girl squad and
i'm with the one and only andrea bottas
we will manage to handle the show
power-wise all right let's
let's hope let's hope you also have
issues i have a good charm for
technology where when i'm around
nothing will break and everything will
work perfectly for the entire day
i promise it's good to know since both
you and
alex had to take a few days off of
streaming because of
the weather conditions in texas we're
happy to see that now things are better
and that you are safe ready to do the
commentary today let's take a look at
the format on what's
going on now with the championship
bracket so this is the very first day
of the championship and consolation
bracket the knockout stage
meaning that the players will be playing
in an eliminatory system the winner will
move on to the next stage to the
semifinals and the loser of today's
matches
will have to say goodbye to the
tournament they are playing
one game each one game with the white
pieces one game with the black pieces
and in case of a tie
after the two games we're gonna go and
see a
sudden death blitz game five minutes no
increment
and you look at also this next slide
with
the big cache lots of money at stake and
many of
many of the prices by the participants
have been already offered for charity
we do have a charity initiative for park
gym 3 as well as the participants
themselves
offering their entire price fund for
charity many of them have already said
it
on their streams which is i think a
wonderful suggestion
that's very sweet the stakes are very
high today
anyone who loses is out it's gonna be
lots of pressure on them
exactly anyone who loses today will take
home four thousand dollars
if they move on to the semi-finals
that's at least six thousand
or more as we can see the winner in the
championship bracket will
take home 20 000 either for themselves
or for their charity speaking of charity
again we do have our community
outreach and we hope to reach 25
000 today if we could show again our bar
and where are we at the moment
with the viewer charity donations so far
we have raised over 17 000
thanks to each and every one of you for
your donations chess.com will be
matching every single penny so make sure
to make them pay as much as possible
they're gonna read
they're gonna match every single
donation up to a hundred
thousand dollars so click on the link in
the banner
in the chat you'll see a charity link
that's where you can donate and every
single penny matters
i think we also have our bracket
beautifully presented now
on what happened after the group stage
today we will be starting with two
matches in the championship
bracket the first one being between the
winner of group b
xqc and the second place player of group
a
sardoche after which we'll move on to
the left side of the bracket
benji fishy the winner of group a will
be taking on
group b's second place player daniel
negrano so
those are the two matches for today the
starting times
are as shown here 120 pacific for the
first match
between xqc and sardoche and the second
match benji fishy
versus daniel negranu at approximately 2
40
pacific tomorrow though andrea tomorrow
is gonna be an
even bigger day with four matches what
are your thoughts
on the pairings for tomorrow honestly
all these i mean all these participants
have been playing so well
i mean even for today the games are so
close i have no idea but
rain has been a monster i think nico has
a really great chance
in the consolation pokemon for smith i'm
so excited to see you we've coached them
both
and i know you've also done a few
coaching with the participants what do
you think is going to be the most
exciting match for tomorrow
i think i'm going to be after hosting a
watch party of my own i'm not doing the
show tomorrow but three of my students
are playing so i'm gonna be there
biting my nails for sure nico versus
rubios is a case where
i have i have given lessons to both of
them i'm gonna do the same i really want
to do a watch party these gay you're
just so emotionally invested when you've
coached them
it's hard man it's really hard it's
really hard and before we get to today's
matches
and what's coming up let's also thank
our sponsor kwayaki
who are celebrating 25 years of
regenerative year by mate and they are
sharing
cases to celebrate with you guys all you
need to do is to spam the goyaki emote
in the chat for a chance to win
and we will be back after a short break
the regeneration of the planet is
integrated into our business model
purchases of guayaqui yerba mate support
stewardship of the south american
atlantic rainforest
and the self-sufficiency of indigenous
communities
these purchases advance a
carbon-balanced renewable energy economy
and provide meaningful employment for
the formerly incarcerated
guayaqui's sales also fuel communities
and
activists driving the regenerative
movement
meanwhile your enjoyment of yerba mate
reconnects you with the vitality of life
when we come to life we care about one
another
and stand together to create a better
future
right and basically like if you do
something like this you can already play
it push push punch
and just try try to attack because he's
pushed the pawns in front of his king
too much here
basically this is a basic setup that i
think is very simple
if he does this i don't think he will do
this but he might do this
um so let's let's take a look at the
other setup he might do
which is he might push his pawn here
yeah
i usually match with the pawn here right
okay so you can match with pawn
yeah he's gonna move his bishop here i
would normally just
go for uh attacking the pawn here like
this okay so this is completely fine and
now he's gonna probably push his pawn
forward
uh like this okay um
i can't want to castle and since i'm
developing right side
sometimes i push uh
sometimes i do this right so this is
this is fine what i actually would say
just to keep it really simple is again
push this pawn
okay and have the theme yeah go ahead
and have the same idea as against the
other opening setup which is actually
when white moves like the knight here
just move the bishop to the center okay
and let's say white trades the bishops
here for example white takes you take
with the queen
yeah and all this whole opening
it it's all around this one square this
is literally the only thing that matters
like
if you don't blender pieces it's all
about the square so like when you move
your bishop here you want to try to push
your pawn
because then you open up this diagonal
for your bishop
okay yeah yeah so let's say white trades
you can take and then when white
moves the bishop for example you can
just push this pawn and you take the
the middle part of the floor yes yes yes
yes yes
yeah it uh it's something i started
doing like that um
it's actually pushing the pawn next to
the other one and then uh
you oh oh sorry uh go back yeah that's
fine
and then you trade it yeah uh i've been
having a problem with it it's sometimes
when i
when i pawn block out mid and i can't
open up both my bishops
and they're like stack bugged totally
so this is probably what i would say is
you basically when this happens
you just want to push so let's just say
white castles just to give a basic
basic idea you push e5 yeah if white
doesn't take you're going to fork
yeah for sure so let's say white takes
and white
trades it all all down you have to push
upon yeah
and now you just move your knight say
castle and you just castle and the idea
is you want to move your bishop here and
put both your rooks in the center of the
board
okay on these two squares and then you
can just play in
the middle game oh yeah this is the idea
okay
let me give you scenario this one
happens very often uh
bishop bishop g4 oh okay sorry in the in
his current position
yeah fifty-four okay like white's move
okay so bishop g4 okay yeah and then
uh let's say he does a pawn pawn f3
well if he does it here you can just
take and you actually
kind of win win the game oh yeah i knew
that already
um well let's say he play he moves the
rook and you do something like this and
he pushes the pawn you can just come
back
and it's the same thing
introducing the grip six belt the only
belt on the market with the no
gut pinch guarantee the grip six is so
light and thin that you'll barely even
notice it's there
it's smooth low profile design makes
this belt the most comfortable belt in
the world
overly confident much you're damn right
because on top of being the most
comfortable belt in the universe
each grip 6 belt comes with our a3 gear
and damn tee
meaning if you don't like any belt for
any reason at any time or in any
condition
you can just contact us and we'll give
you a full refund
thank you so much to gravesix for their
sponsorship and make sure to use
pogchamps 20 as a code to get
20 percent off on any product on their
site if you go to
go.chess.com unfortunately the wallets
have been sold at the chest in words but
they still have
the chest steam belts and their premium
chest set is available for pre-order
take advantage of that yeah they sent us
a little belt and it had a queen shape
in the buckle i think alex can rock
these
yes we did i'm so jealous oh
it must be a europe thing maybe like the
mail didn't make it i bet it's coming
though
i hope so i'm thinking it's just taking
longer because levy got his socks and
then he almost did a sock reveal and i
think yeah
i would love to have one of those as
well and uh again make sure to use
the code until you can during the event
it's a 20
off on their site we are ready to start
the first match of the championship
bracket again
these are two of the biggest grinders of
the pak cham series xqc the only
participant who has played in
every single edition and sardoche he has
started his chess grind
at the beginning of 2021 playing chess
almost every single day on his stream
for hours and hours grinding through
lessons
and over 2 800 chess games
so i'm curious how this game will turn
out
we were watching earlier andrea the
preparation of sqc
with none other than grandmaster hikaru
nakamura what did you think of that
london preparation which will be for the
second game not this one
yeah they were preparing against the
london which is my
favorite but the games have started
so i think we can hop right in um
xcc is not playing the london i'm a
little bit disappointed but we'll take
it
and i i will definitely see it by sardo
stardust does love
your london system just as much as as
you do i believe
e4 and let's see if sardosh
realizes that he is in the game i'm
looking at his screen
and for now it doesn't seem like he
noticed
that yeah started he was having
connection issues he started with one
bar
but i don't know what's going on now
please
let's try this again this game started
let's try this again take number two xqc
versus sardoche
the winner of group b with the white
pieces versus
the second place player of group a sarah
i'm going to call my brother because we
have like the same name so
now we're technically related okay
i agree that that's a good call there
let's say it called in the
sicilian defense let's see if xqc
has made any preparations against a
sicilian or will he just
freestyle it his intuition is extremely
good he played some very sharp games in
the group stage
even the gambits that daniel negrano has
played against xqc felix managed to come
back
with the most most accurate responses
the most precise responses in the
opening which is not
easy to do when you face gambit you
please
bishop to c4 and i don't know if he has
anything prepped but
his development looks pretty solid so
far but he has been grinding so much and
it's definitely been paying off in his
games
exactly he played this setup also
against daniana grano he likes to place
the bishop on c4
i guess that comes from the usual e4e5
openings where we teach everyone that oh
that's a good spot to attack the f7 pawn
and he does the same against the
sicilian yeah
i like to call this a reverse london
everything comes back to the london but
all right it's always about the london i
like the setup that stardust has gone
for
because the bishop on c4 can be
dangerous pointing at that
f7 spot after e6 you make your spawn
structure more solid and the king's
safer
yeah sardochi is not gonna be falling
through any traps today
i don't think he will you're right he is
the highest rated player
very impressive 1400 rating points he
was
almost at 1500 at some stage a week a
week or so ago
so it's incredible to see how he started
out about at the rating of 900 in
january
and he has gained over 600 rating points
since
yeah his rating is very impressive but i
think xpc is
a very close in level so even though
he's a little bit underrated i think
this matchup is going to be very close
absolutely i don't think anyone is a
favorite i i feel like they are very
very even when it comes to their their
expertise in terms of how many games
they have been grinding through over
2000 games of both of them
and how well they did in the group stage
both of them well xqc won his group
stage and sardosh was close to tying the
score
against benji fish in that crucial match
all right so here
he did do you think that sardochi is
playing a little bit defensive
only pushing his pawns one move not
really controlling the center yet
what do you think of sardosh's reply to
xqc's opening
i think it's solid and i feel like
sardosh has
prepared for this he must have seen that
xqc does have couple of games with this
bishop c4 setup so i don't think it came
as a surprise to him also he has been
playing very fast
that still has more than 10 minutes oh
my god
it's 10 minutes with a five second
increment per move so so far stardust
has been collecting time not spending
time
yeah i didn't even realize where all the
time went xqc is already
down to almost eight minutes okay i like
it he's putting in an attack the
bishop's probably gonna have to retreat
the b3 here he's getting a little bit of
aggressive play
b5 is a typical push indeed in the
sicilian later
black and developed the bishop to the
long diagonal bishop to b7
i wonder if xqc will choose bishop to b3
or drop the bishop back to f1
d3 there are also available squares on
that diagonal
so let's see which one is his reference
yeah i think both lines are good
i'm taking a quick look at his screen
and he is drawing an arrow to the
b3 square so so far good
i like it that would be a very logical
decision to keep the bishop on that
diagonal
if he is not worried that the bishop can
get trapped because the only downside of
it would be if black manages to push
the a pawn all the way to a4 then
there's no space for the bishop it's not
happening
as of now of course yeah i think this
one is the most natural and easiest to
play where if he was retreating here
he might be blocking some of his own
pieces so comfortable play so far for
xqc
let's listen in what he thinks about
this position i wonder
i promise this knight is not very
protected only by queen
which believes you're kind of vulnerable
oh wait a minute queen pawn push
double attack thank you that's another
one
three at ricardo prep
he gonna go for it now this is no longer
protected though
do i care i mean if he did go queen f3
just bishop b7 right counteracting right
away
yes that would be a good response but
sardosh has to find it so let's see
first of all it's a double attack i'm
going to go for it
okay
i like it putting him under pressure
okay
let's bring our board back and show what
the idea of felix is here with queen
f3 he is ready to push his e pawn to e5
and that would mean that both the knight
on f6
and the rook on a8 would be hanging but
unfortunately for him sardosh
immediately
plays the best response bishop to b7
another pawn is pinned you cannot push
e5 because that would be
as we know we all know
it yeah the thing with these moves is
like box blocks call them they're
serotonin moves it looks nice
because he has this one move threat but
now he pretty much just helped black
develop
and now his queen's a little bit pinned
yeah
i think if he realizes that the queen
though is doing well in the third rank
he can even shift it to
for instance g3 to then try to attack
the king on g8 with the
bishop move to h6 that would be a way to
set up a checkmate pattern
but no he doesn't go toward the king he
drops the queen back to
e2 so he's i think insisting on this
idea that the pawn at some point should
be pushed
yeah he really wants to attack in the
center which i think is a pretty pretty
solid plan
so far i wonder if sardoche will follow
up with the knight development that
would be the next for him
to finish the development of the queen
side plays the knight on c6 or d7 both
of them are logical
yeah so far i'm a big fan of both of
their openings
definitely this is very high level
opening preparation i would say but from
excuse his side i'm not even sure it's
preparation i think he has just a really
good intuition for chess already after
2000 games played
i agree now this is an interesting move
he's a little bit over extending his
pawns but
now if the knight comes to the side he
doesn't necessarily have squares to go
so
where do you think xcc should be
rerouting his knights
good question i i feel like knight a4
would be um the square he's looking at
at the same time i wonder if he will
notice that now the e4 pawn is no longer
well enough guarded that was the knight
the knight on c3 was protecting the e4
pawn and now the bishop and the black
knight from f6 are
attacking the pawn they could be taking
on could be the first fallen pawn and he
was
he was trying so hard to push this guy
too but
might not even get the chance yeah
that's the bit of a downside of this
queen move that he played because
earlier the rook two was guarding the
pawn the
queen the knight so many pieces of felix
were protecting the central palm but you
don't want the capture to be starting
with the queen
he has the strongest defenders but he
just can't
take because of this little bishop it's
very sad both his rook and his queen
working together hard but
all right there goes his pawn it's okay
can come back from it
i feel like because he's ahead in
development he does have compensation if
he keeps
playing very aggressive and
developing moves developing meaning that
he also still needs to develop the c1
bishop
and bring in the other rook as well
bring the other rook to d1 possibly
so if he would for instance now um make
a developing move with the bishop
or chase the knight away with f3 if he
has to oh he goes
okay f3 i kind of like it i mean
a little bit blocking this bishop but it
is creating some weaknesses on this
diagonal here
but if he's not falling for any checks i
don't think there'll be any traps
i fully agree with you and now it is
over to
sardosh to see where do you place the
knight
and there could be tactics on the e6
square i feel like if the knight simply
goes back to f6
we we could see a sacrifice on e6
that would be a very nice sack actually
uh some of the chatters were pointing
out the sacrifice earlier in the game
but
this is this is hard because even if he
goes to c5
we could take and sack so he has to play
very
precisely here to g5
i'm not even sure what is it that
sardosh is supposed to be playing here
because
as you said doesn't matter if you go to
f6 or c5 in both cases the knight
the knight will be taken on c5 and then
the e6 sacrifice
is possible let's just show for a moment
until sardos is thinking
this knight f6 position and what happens
oh okay
he hasn't alexandra your idea here i
think i think that knight on c5 will be
taken i think phillips
this would be a killer tactic if he
found technically he just played a
gambit here from knight takes e4
like if he's playing perfectly that was
a pretty nice pawn sacrifice
indeed let's show it on on our analysis
board i feel like because it's a
it's a long variation to take on c5
which eliminates the defender of the e6
pawn after dtx c5 knight takes e6
sacrificing the knight and if the pawn
takes it queen takes e6
is a check which also attacks the bishop
on e7 and you cannot defend with rook to
f7 thanks to this very powerful bishop
on b3
i wonder if felix will see it i wonder
if he spots this tactical [ __ ]
and take the knight and then sacrifice
on e6 that would
be five head absolute five head if he
sees it yeah i'll show the line again
but sorry don't look so stressed man
what do you think he spotted it do you
think he that there was danger
he did look look at him he looks he
looks like he's sweating i think he
knows but i don't know if xqc knows
maybe we can see if he's going to find
this line
he played a3 instead which is not a bad
move and
it could still allow that sacrifice
later i didn't give him
a free nice pawn development this is
fine i missed this shot
what oh
the issue is that now sardoche had a
chance to
trade the knight for the bishop that
bishop was a key piece for this tactical
motive
how do you prefer this yes sardosh
definitely saw the tactic did not want
to give him a sec
man that would have been because then my
palms aren't towered and i can still
push them up
and then i can i get this plate whenever
this queen is out of position
what is that not even that bad
if you leave spawn there i'm gonna have
triple stacked pawns that's terrible
let's see normal puns that is true
how much
we're good we're down by one pump but
we're actually good here
i do i need to do better moves my time i
need to just make moves make moves
i'm overthinking it just chill out man
you hurry
he he's still on the same sacrifice
doesn't he
i think it wouldn't work the same way if
we bring back our analysis board because
now without the bishop if he ends up
taking on e6
the rook will be defending at the end of
the line you tell us the rook f7
d5 is a great move by sardosh i was
going to say
he reacted with the central palm push
allowing the trade on b4 but now after
bishop takes b4
this bishop is really well placed
attacking the rook on e1
and then he could develop his knight so
his upper pawn has a really healthy pawn
structure and he just needs to finish
the clean side development
yeah unfortunately his triple stack did
not survive very long
we're down to a double stack or double
pawns
but i kind of like the stack terminology
better
no triple stack we do have the double
stack and the pawn then for felix so he
needs
to compensate for it with aggressive
attacking ideas let's see what he can
come up with and will sardos trade the
bishop
on d2 or will he drop it back because if
he preserves the bishop if he keeps it
and goes back to that say d6
he would also have the pair of bishops
which is
a strategic advantage on an advanced
level and i feel like this
is already advanced level so he might
actually consider keeping it on the
board
yeah another thing to note he's also up
on the clock so
it is looking pretty good for sardoshier
okay you chose to offer the trade which
is also good you want to trade when
you're up material
but i'm not sure that he should allow
them before so
i agree with you that trading overall
it could be beneficial to him but knife
bishop takes
eight takes b4 that bottom b4 will be
vulnerable and queen to b5 would attack
both the
bishop on b7 and the pawn on b4 so xqc
has a chance to win the pawn back if he
spots that although queen b5 queen e7
that's still not
over but it would make sardosh's life
more difficult to develop the knight
from b8 at least
it is exactly what you're saying he's a
little bit down so he needs to get an
attack going and this could be the
opportunity for that
let's see if he spots it if we go over
to his stream and listen in
oh he's looking at it maybe
there we go he's gonna do it
well i don't know what i'm doing here
no he found like the good idea
what
know what i'm doing he gave up on it and
are you excited about that
check yeah he should have trusted that
idea but sometimes it has
instincts
nope it's a bit too late for the
sacrifice though
yeah no longer working god a little bit
too late
move take take is that good it's decent
it's very it's very unpredictable he's
really over thinking
the issue is here when you don't know
what to do you spend so much time
looking at all pretty decent moves but
he's already down more than half the
time so rook trade
it's not bad he ends up playing knight
to c5 if we bring our
board back i think um the reason why the
other
move order would have been better and he
was drawing an arrow to the b5 square so
he literally
almost played queen to b5 now the
difference is if
if for instance they trade on a1 rook
takes even rook takes a1 and then
queen to b6 could be somewhat annoying
because you have both of your knights
on that diagonal hanging and
you need to find a way in which you can
guard the c5 knight so that it will not
fall there's a pin over the d4 night
and both knights are vulnerable i'm not
even sure what's the best way
to continue there sardosh is taking the
rook he is trading on a1 let's see if he
follows up with
queen to b6 or any similar idea about
the knights being somewhat exposed and
vulnerable on the diagonal the long
the long diagonal yeah this is getting
into a really tough
position here he didn't even have
counter play to take the bishop
and try to attack the queen because then
he would have given him a check earlier
so
he is in a little bit of a messy
position oh wow and he plays it
sardoch has been playing so accurate
he's playing really well and after queen
to b6 i wonder if if the only move for
xqc
is either a sad rook c1 when black can
continue with
rook c8 bringing yet another piece to
the attack or he will eventually
need to trade queens he has to
probably place the queen on b5 the move
he was looking at earlier
and offer a queen trade before it's too
late now the house is on fire so he
i think he should trade queens yeah
queen week five here i mean once again
trading down material but
his knights are pretty strong he has
pressure on the bishop he has the open
file so
a queen trade he still has chances for
sure
i agree let's go over to a history
actually wait a second he has made a
decision
but it's not it's not the end of the
painful part and how difficult it will
be with that pin
if sardoche continues with rook to c8
and i think he has to play that's the
last way you can defend
or just move back like this then
and i can fork this oh yeah
oh yeah oh yeah move queen here and fork
that
those knight frogs are good ideas but
unfortunately it's not happening they
don't
work regarding the square and now rook
c8 that is
the best move that sardoche has found is
that what i can do here
wow he's going to trade he's into it is
he oh
we could bring our board back and show
what's happening in this position with
that c5 knight unfortunately for xqc
this is now pinned through the c5
through the diagonal knight to a6 adds
yet another attacking piece
to what's going on on this c5 square
that's the key square here that's the
key piece the c5 knight
is going to fall there's not another
piece that white can bring here to the
defense the d4 knight unfortunately is
unable to guard their body on c5 you
cannot protect it
yeah queen b5 was the only way he has
the same situation when he pinned this
queen earlier
and now we can't save the piece it's
getting really tough
he doesn't even have any like tactics
try to stack oh
okay is playing knight to d7
to try to bait sardo but he's losing his
rook
yeah that's so quick he didn't even have
to double check he was so confident that
he's taking
the queen and then the rook so both
queens are off of the board but this is
now an
extra rook for sardosh yeah
i mean look at he looks like he's at a
serious chest right now he's so
focused you know when like half your
face is covered by your hands you're in
your zone he's
been killing it he's certainly in the
zone and he's on his way of
claiming the first game with an extra
rook he's about to take on b2
as well i think he'll just collect that
pawn and then
possibly in the future push in the
center or try to win the b3 pawn as well
to create a past pawn
i can't tell if silence there's no is
yeah is it
not even any music oh there he is we now
do hear
his stream but i think i think it's
gonna be the background music and
the silence of his thoughts yeah i don't
think he's saying anything much
here but luckily i excuse
that hikaru for next round so anything
can happen
true true true let's see if xqc
the gm he carries preparation against
the london can
fight back in the next game
unfortunately for xqc this end game
is just very unlikely that one can go
wrong
it would take a mouse slip or
time pressure that could get to black
but stardosh has more time as well
so yeah more time i mean this this extra
rook is just
yeah all the fawns are gonna fall his
knights can't defend everything
i don't know where he's trying to run
maybe he's trying to set up a stalemate
or something
i think so i think he places the king on
h4 because you're right that could still
be a pattern if the king has nowhere to
go and he manages to sacrifice yeah
actually if there was no pawn no night
and no other night we would have had a
stalemate
it was a great plan we just had to
remove some more pieces
he's trying to stack them he's going to
give them all he's going to give
everything
i think that's what we're going to see
exactly and
we shall see we shall see it will if it
will work out
xqc has had his fair share of stalemates
in previous sport chimps editions and i
think he's very well aware that that's
his last chance here
that is true but something tells me from
sardosh's
place so far he's not going to fall for
any rookie mistakes
and he's going for the b3 pawn which is
very logical once you eliminate that
pawn
you have a pass pawn three squares away
from promotion so rick takes b3 and then
move the rook away
so that you can freely push the pawn
toward b1
yeah this is killer xqc decided against
his stillmate player now he's
defending his knights oh he doesn't take
the b3 comes to attack f4
interesting i would have i would have
predicted
that the capture will happen maybe
sardoch is considering that
it could be a checkmate pattern he
wanted to take on f4
he can still do it after h6 check and
king h4 rook takes f4
yeah he should have tried to retreat to
g3
let's see where the route goes there
aren't too many squares phonically
enough for that rook
just hear yesterday maybe f1 you should
just come chase the spawn and then
the finishing touch will be this passer
here
g5 is a great move too to support the
rook with that palm push so
black is up a rook and also a couple of
past pawns at this stage
he didn't take the b-bomb but he also
has the d-pawn as a passport so
d4 and then trying to push d3 would be
another way oh he's going for the
stalemate plan and he's gonna give
everything yeah stalemate plan and also
knight forks
and felix wants to take on e6 to win the
rook and if king takes a fight here
he has another knight fork knight to g6
unfortunately for him he's giving away
all his knights for the rook but he's
really trying he's really trying
yeah the sad part like even with this
nice tactic
i mean he just has this little king
against and his two pawns
not much going here
now the rook is gone for the two nights
and what remains on the board is still
unfortunately
very very tough for xqc it's
two extra pieces and four pawns four
best
ones for ourselves all right
okay they did trade how to catch up here
well okay and the the stalemate chances
are looking better and better what can i
say
we gotta push that honey here we go now
it's just the king against the world
but i i don't think i don't know if his
dreams are going to come true
let's see if it's going to be stalemate
or checkmate we are just a few moves
away from
seeing the reality if quinterjeet
he shouldn't bring the queen that close
he brings the king in and now it's
checkmate on the board
for his game no mercy at all wow
yeah excuse he really threw everything
he had for that stalemate but sardoche
played very clean that was a killer game
that was indeed a killer game and we're
gonna be back with a second game with
colors reversed as you mentioned for the
next game
it's gonna be the preparation of gm
hikaru against the london system so
hopefully that will go better for xqc
because he did have his chances in this
game too
with that sacrifice on e6 if he has
spotted it yeah if
if they if sardos plays into hikaru's
prep
i think maybe we could go into an
armageddon
let's take a look at xqc stream and
we're going to be back in a few minutes
with the second game program 3 presented
by grip6
attack [ __ ] okay oh attack
packages do
okay
you guys well my name's not starting
well when's the start next match
four pillars of regeneration to heal all
nations
we work with and not against because we
are a part of this
we've never been apart from this saw
hands feel through the soils past
our feet touch on the blades of grass
raid all these voices into a beautiful
tapestry find those similarities we all
share in these breaths that we breathe
this home of ours sustains us but needs
us
so together we'll move through this long
night and inspire us all to come to life
thank you so much again to guyaki for
helping pakistan be possible
helping us to make this event be
possible and they are sharing
cases of the year by mate to celebrate
25 years of
regenerative year by mate all you need
to do you already
know it you already should know it by
now spam those goyaki emotes in the chat
with a chance to win a case also to
share
their celebration guayaki emotes right
now
right now let me say when i they sent us
a big
big package of a bunch and when i drank
those i gained 100 points in bullet
true story
i need my kids to actually i have
received my kids but i need more kids
i need more i think any caffeine kind of
pays off in bullets
but uh this is like a healthier version
so
absolutely absolutely right and we have
a lift off i believe for the second game
sardoche won the first game meaning that
xqc is in a must-win
situation he has to win if he doesn't
win
eliminated the london system android's
already getting excited let's see the gm
he
preparation this is the game i've been
looking forward to man
because i don't play a single other
opening as white except the london
system so when i see it
i get really excited because it's you
know the one thing i've studied a lot
all right so far so good knight to c6 is
the move that he
was showing to xqc with the setup being
e6 and bishop to d6
so let's see if felix follows up along
the lines
of the super gm preparation yeah i
remember when we popped into a stream
it seemed like they would get into
position where they trade this
bishop i'm curious if that'll happen i
don't trade it very often so we talked
about
okay i'm losing memory this is according
to the plan e6
and sargon
oh no
no he forgot the plan king check pawn
move
pawn move back
then who knows
trend the juicer i think he just wanted
to scare his him
it's just a little bit of scared he
doesn't yeah yeah
okay yeah he was looking at bishop check
which okay
sneak it back f4 for a moment because we
have
the jungle system expert with us andrea
what do you think of this f4 push if you
could show it on our board
well um actually f4 is uh
incorrect and so now i don't think we're
gonna be playing into the ikaru position
but i mean it's
it's okay but now we've kind of created
this weakness
and normally you want your bishop to be
defending here a little bit
a premature pawn push that is from the
london expert
i see i see so you wouldn't have pushed
f4
but even if it's not perhaps the best
approach by white
sardoch does have his plan to avoid the
bishop trade
and support the e5 square and he
immediately jumps to e5 with his knight
and then the next
night the other night could come to f3
as well so
i like that he's got a setup very very
clear in his mind and he's going for it
yeah this is still a pretty common plan
for the london he just pushed surely but
it's still
pretty easy to play pretty comfortable
but he might have some king side
weaknesses depending if xqc
packs in the center as well but he did
not have that prep
so it will be harder to find that's the
issue
this f4 push whether it was the best or
not it has prevented
the gm recovery preparation where they
mainly were focusing on positions with
the trade of bishops now the trade of
the bishop for the e5 knight how do you
see the opening of the f-file in this
system
i i think i mean this is okay i i think
these pawns are pretty strong and that
now we have the bishop pair
sometimes i get really annoyed when you
know they copy you and then they come do
the same thing and get their own pawns
and then
even push f5 too but i don't know if xqc
is going to come for the center
let's see if he's going toward e4 with
the knight or
d7 the knight doesn't have any other
options where it wouldn't be taken for
free
but yeah i must say what sardochi is
doing sometimes when i get paired
against
really high rated players i i make sure
that i'm not playing theory
because i feel like then you kind of
have better chances even if it's
slightly wrong
all right we got a knight d7 playing
safe
that's solid and the night later could
jump to f8 if the king needs more
protection
i wonder if sardoche will continue with
bishop d3 and castle king's side or will
he even consider castle queenside
yeah i think bishop d3 is the right plan
he probably pushed c3 to avoid some
knight before attacking the bishop
his development is looking good
c3 is the traditional push i guess he
may have been worried about bishop to d3
knight
b4 yeah so the hard thing here
and i was going to ask you what do you
think the best plan for xqc to develop
is
because his pieces are all pretty
passive and all bunched up together and
retreated already
it's tough you're right with the the
knight on d7
the way of the bishop oh f6 though
i was gonna say i think you need to try
to to explode that central structure of
white
f6 is the way to go but bishop h4 by
stardust immediately to pin the
pawn he is so fast no this is yeah this
is a great because
his pieces could not develop anywhere he
has to break through somewhere but
sardosa is playing these
fantastic moves so fast
this is a really tough situation for sqc
because he did have the right plan but
now you are not able to take on e5
because of the pin
and pushing the pawn to g5 would be too
committal he should definitely not
weaken his king
oh no no no he thinks it
thanks banana saw your faults
okay i mean maybe it can still turn out
well but i feel like this is
too committal yeah now just excuses
king is almost naked and afraid look at
all these holes
but you can bring in the troops maybe
and he could be winning the pawn so i
guess his reasoning is that if the
bishop
goes back to g3 then he could take
multiple times on e5 queen to g4
by sardosh to now pin the g pawn as well
he's definitely
a master of pins spinning now yeah also
the second pawn on g5 i wonder is it
tricky sacrifice is now on e5
because if knight takes e5 pawn takes
and then you take again on e5 with the
knight you have given up a piece but the
queen has to leave and then you could
trap a trap not but take the bishop
on h4 except if the queen goes to g3
right
because then we can maintain in that
case i think my plan is ruined yes
it was a good idea wait wait wait no
damn
the bishop because then you can move the
king away from the jeep
and the bishop has nowhere to go i
didn't see that coming but it
makes some sense that's true i think i
mean yeah white is still going to be
killing this position
yeah and it looks too dubious looks too
suspicious because the bishop could have
taken on g5 so we are
in the midst of our analysis why excuses
simply pushes h6 to
structure which maybe it was probably
safer than sacrificing but this is
still it's just so much attack on his
king so early
and he's so behind development on the
queen side
i think h6 is indeed a really good
practical decision in order to make the
king
safer and he could in the future push
the f pawn now that the g
pawn is so well guarded he could go f5
to try to chase that
queen away f5 would be a really nice way
to try to block this
opening here on his king and then maybe
he could even bring in his queen to
defend eventually
and then again those ideas would be
possible that after f5 queen g3
you move the king away from the g file
and the bishop on h4 is trapped
at some point it should work
yeah so now it's up to sardosh maybe
he's gonna see this idea
try to prevent it and play something
safe like we're treating as bishop
or even more aggressive i wonder i guess
he doesn't have any sack idea like queen
h5
take the bishop give some checks and
clean up his pawns
there's a lot of ideas for white wait a
second he won the first game
so if he finds a way in which he can
force a perpetual
you would be claiming the match so it's
it makes a lot of sense for him to look
for queen h5 queen g6 and try to give
perpetual yeah
actually i think this is a perpetual
because
king f8 queen check and here then we
have
a mate threat so so there actually is a
force
well if they take the bishop though so
queen h5 is an interesting name
i think you have just solved the match
if he
spots queen to h5 which either
is with a really strong attack for white
or if the bishop is accepted
it's a perpetual check for white that's
all
that sardoche needs and this is the
match situation i think if it was just a
normal game
why should try to play this for a win
because the position is better
but with a draw and only a draw you can
you can wow the next stage to the
semi-finals he plays bishop
instead which is which is very ambitious
but it may not be
oh my god it's now the advantages in
black side i
i think maybe the plan is f5 but the
eval bar took a big drop
i think he has stepped into the
sacrifice i was trying to make it
knight takes e5 you've been oh oh the
knight one not even the f5
okay let's play it out live so that when
d takes another knight takes and now the
queen
and the bishop are hanging and if you
drop the queen back to e2 to guard the
d3 bishop then the h4 bishop is taken so
you cannot guard both bishops
wow wow okay i don't want to miss it
let's see
if he's gonna if xqc is gonna find it
yeah f5 was a little bit of a safer move
still blocking the attack but that was a
really complicated
tactic there f5 push my xqc which is
again logical but
i'm afraid he's pushing star dodge to
finding queen to h5
afterwards
[Music]
but if it's a draw he's eliminated so
again because it's
the knockout stage already xqc has to
win
to earn a tiebreaker yeah excuse me had
two
very killer tactics in each game but
there are both
you know a couple moves of calculating
they're pretty hard to spot
these are no puzzle rush tactics that
you get in your first 10
puzzles or something now this was very
complex the sacrifice on e5 the first
time i went for the sacrifice it didn't
even work so
yeah i didn't even see it the second
time around
so if queen h5
i think sardosh will be claiming the
match because i don't even see a way for
black to
avoid the checks or not lose the h6 pawn
so it's either way too dangerous the
attack or you accept the fact that you
can take the bishop but then you will
not
run away from the checks any other queen
move i do think that
xqc has a chance because if you drop the
queen back to g3
again black could consider moving away
the king from the g
file and then the h4 bishop is trapped
again this is the tactical motif we were
trying to make
work and i think it's working yeah this
would be pretty nice because
the queen will also defend g5 so it's
not even like white can sack a lot
you know what do we miss wait into g3
g3 wow stardust didn't play queen to h5
but places the queen on g3 so let's see
if xqc will not by moving the king away
i i might am i moving to the atria i
don't know i feel a bit more concerned
about the f5 but it's just my intuition
i'm not
i'm not 100 sure but if he moves the
king away from the g5
let's say king to h7 then the bishop on
h4 will
so this is still very tricky though i
like that he didn't choose to take the
pawn
which would have helped excuse his pawn
structure but now we have this isolated
pawn and this open file
let's go back to exclusive stream and
see if he's thinking of
rook to g8 or queen g5 i'm gonna go for
it
i'm going for it
oh no i lost i'm so dumb
[Music]
he's giving up no reason
it's not bad though it's fine
check i realize that that's only a check
yeah
i think it's really easy to get that
losing mentality when i don't even know
i force trade because i'm plus two and i
wanna go for trades
in a better position even with better
pawns too thinking to go for trades
yeah he's thinking about some some crazy
fort move here he's gonna find it
no he won't before i don't think there's
any pork knight g6 doesn't lead to
anything
if i were to stack my juices like this
he would just go
boom
what does that even do from
take queen good castle
got some kick play well now we're in the
end game the next he has
the advantage
and he goes for rook j it's very logical
to try to take the pawns on the g
yes i just
okay
the queen side development indeed we
need to get that c8 bishop
l so b6 is a good uh
unfortunately is his center pawn that
across is fine on whites are really
holding his bishop back
i like knight to b6 because that also
frees the d7
square for the bishop so he could do
that exactly
exactly that's the way to go connecting
the rooks
you can bring them on time easy
development
i need to figure what figure out a way
to attack that
that's decent
the pawn push
this piece is rolling right now i need
to get it out thank you
let's bring our board back for a moment
and see some of these options
uh again this is a great chance for xqc
to make a comeback
sardoch is leading 1-0 in this match and
it's already the knockout stage meaning
that xqc
has to win this game he's now up a piece
and all that sardosh has is a pawn to
compensate for it not
much especially considering that it's
not a past pawn
and they're stacked as we say not
doubled
exactly stacked pawns oh and now
g4 offering the pawn i don't know if
sardosh miscalculated it that there are
two pieces of black attacking that
square
yes he takes the pawn wow
oh he was planning to win it back but i
mean black can just defend his pawn here
he might have miscalculated that now
there's h5
porsche wow the pawn and the rook on g3
is stuck so it's not only that he lost
the player anywhere the phone
on its own wouldn't be that much of a
disaster but the fact that you cannot
move your
rook ever how will he activate the g3
rook
oh no i was gonna say just has to watch
out for this night check
he's been preparing but we all right
oh okay so xqc did step into the night
fork but it's
not the end of the world if if he will
take one of
the minor pieces for it so he can either
take on g6 or move the king and then
take back on f8
yeah there's there's a few
i think even after i think he has
already made his decision before we
could have listened and he does take on
g6 but now he has to be careful with
those paws the h5 pawn is hanging and if
he loses that pawn the g4 pawn two will
fall
yeah he only has one way to defend his
pawn bishop eight he
right now even though he just lost
exchange he's still doing much better
because he has this past pawn here
but he can't drop these pawns yes he's
got two minor pieces for the rook but he
has to guard the pawns and you're right
andrew it's not so easy to find
bishop e8 or or something tricky with
the knight jumps if
if he gets over to to f5 but that's way
too dank knight t7 to then go knight oh
he's dropping them these were the key
the key to the success oh no
oh and now it's back in white's favor
the g3 rook was completely dead and now
it's back in the game after the g4 pawn
he's breaking free from the chains of
this pawn and
taking two pawns almost and there goes
another one
oh man oh no and the issue with the king
to h6 is that
after rook age war wow or bishop g4
there will be checkmate patterns too now
yeah we got the rook roller here holding
back the king we just have to take this
pawn
wow
what a turn of events excuse me with the
piece of
but he did not see that night for coming
rook fade would have been a logical move
if it wasn't for the tactical pattern
and now this should be mating too
uh rook takes g4 king goes back to h6
and this cover check mate
and if king to f5 and now it's just made
in one
oh god oh my goodness yes
yes
[Music]
his quarterfinals 2-0 against sqc
moves on to the semi-finals we will be
back with the players
in a few minutes to discuss everything
that has happened what a roller coaster
and what a missed chance
by sqc in the second game that was a
very close game
poor guy but sardosh sure he he grinded
these two games he stayed in it when he
was losing
and he got that one tactic saved the
game that night fork
did turn the tables and did secure the
win for star dodge
we're gonna take a short break and then
we will be back with the players
to discuss all this action from the
quarter finals of the championship
bracket
blockchain 3 presented by grif6 will be
back shortly
xd yeah rook over was
you got to win this man look we got some
sweaters in this top this [ __ ] ain't
gonna be free i wish
i was rolling though he was actually
rolling
why is this good
what was that even cheaper oh bang than
bing then i have a i have a fork
coot saw that i'm just saying you right
now coot saw that
cooter saw that
i'm sad i feel like you should have won
that game five thousand of you are now
manually breathing dude i had it
damn that dude i had it i'm telling you
[ __ ] up because i think he made at
least a hundred thousand people just
manually breathe you see i finally got a
girlfriend
so i don't have much time come on bro
thanks for everything oh we're also on
chess.com
so [ __ ] 200 000 people are now
manually breathing
bang i guess that's the most
value anyone's ever gotten out of a
teacher yes wonders well i mean my king
was the best initiative
dude he played so sick too he played so
sick because even without any blunders
sardoche basically went all in with an
attack and he fended it off
he fended off the entire attack and then
just unfortunately
it works how does it work
i think sardosh is beatable is this
crazy i think sardosha is definitely
beatable
because sardoche after getting i think
up on time after
his first eight moves or something like
he was literally up on time because he
moved faster than five seconds every
move
ended up taking four minutes for four
moves
and like he like he cares so much about
winning
that i think it makes him worse at the
game
maybe that's crazy to say but he cares
so much about winning
he's so sweaty about it
that when it really comes down to the
wire
like he can't handle the pressure like
if you got a minute to play and all you
want in this world is to win
that's too much man
that sucks though i wanted it to at
least go to overtime i just want to see
the new overtime as well
who plays next mizzy yeah mizzy's doing
this quiz i gave him
i gave a bunch of streamers the
internet's hardest questions logically
world's gay is dead right okay lasagna
oh it's this is the question okay here's
a here's a question for everybody at
home
if you have two lasagnas that you've
baked and then you stacked one on top of
the other how many lasagnas do you have
still tastes like water which means
that didn't help us at all water's a
terrible example for this oh [ __ ] thank
you for the sub
god why is this making me hungry
yeah i'm going to order all of you guys
by the way just put whatever you want
i'm getting it from burger king whatever
you guys want
uh my mom's on the way she's on like
route 33. you have to disclose
when it's sponsored burger king if you
guys segment
just put it whatever you want in chat
she'll get it my mom reads chat and
drives
um no she doesn't wait lud just came in
here
no one eats burger king if they're not
paid is that one of the questions led
will you eat burger king unpaid i'm
gonna be real with you lud my grandma
used to get me
two double cheeseburgers and a milkshake
every time and you know why i love
burger king
was made last week and one today you
know why i like burger king
burger king was good because of not the
food but the atmosphere man
it was the car that you got to sit in
eating your big mac with the crown on
your head and it was just divine
what the [ __ ] playhouse was a better
vibe than that
[ __ ] nowadays the playhouse i look at it
and i'm like damn that's a disgusting
pit of like toxic waste but back in the
day the play pit
that [ __ ] was i'm too smart for my own
good if you bake two lasagnas
and then he also said big mac
i love going to bk and get my big mac
and you stack one lasagna on top of each
other
okay here's my argument for why it's two
if you bake
a lasagna and then let's say the next
week you bake another lasagna
and you stack one on top of the other
how many would you have you would say
two
boom
you argue the stacking is all that
matters your answer would have to be yes
which makes no
sense you're [ __ ] here's the thing
that is destroyed that becomes the issue
i totally agree
yes but the problem is it is the crust
does it start a new lasagna
it does start a new lasagna that's where
the issue comes into play
welcome back to the coverage of
pogchamps 3 presented by grips
we're grape six we are being joined by d
heroes of the first
ever championship bracket clash between
sardoche and xqc
sir dosh congratulations this has been a
nail-biting finish
and xqc you almost made a miracle happen
as i was telling you
while we were getting ready for the
interview let's begin
with you sardosh about first of all your
thoughts on these two games and how do
you feel about making
making it to the semi-finals well it was
very very stressful because uh i knew
xqc was really good in open position and
so otherwise so i could get punished if
i go for tactics
so well i i tried to close it up a bit
uh i knew he had the preparation for my
london system by icaru just before the
stream
but sadly i had my coach telling me
exactly how to actually
quintus so i'm really sorry but my coach
phone on this one
is that a shout out to blitzstream kevin
boardy or nemo
hey kevin kevin on this one yeah
but on this c4 i must admit i would have
never found it myself by myself
that was kevin kevin body yeah sorry
sorry i'm really sorry but the game was
really intense i put myself in a so hard
situation
in the white game and you you did so
well with your pawns i was
in so much trouble and well i i gave up
my
my bishop and went like okay maybe my
maybe my knight will
do the job and he did at the end so i'm
proud that well that was a bit lucky
yeah the bishop was stuck on the left
side of the map
and
[Laughter]
i'm just kidding yeah yeah i thought uh
the bishop and the queen were uh were
like stack uh upper left
uh but the only thing is that uh at mid
there's like a a four
trade i could have done that i didn't
see and the computer kept saying it
wrong wrong like he didn't want me to do
it but i i
didn't see it again get aggressive with
it are you talking about the night fork
or
in the very first game yeah the night
sacrifice should knight take nails
yeah that would have been nice right
before f5
anna pointed this one out yeah in first
game i had either there was a tactic i
missed it
yeah in both games actually it was a
very instructive motive but such a
difficult one to find
um andrea i thank you for sharing the
right moment there with knight takes e5
that's the one felix was referring to
that here you could have sacrificed the
knight
and now uh the queen is hanging the
bishop on d3s hanging
and also the h4 bishop will be in the
area if the queen moves away from the g5
so you would have won the pete's back
and you're up couple of pawns
oh yeah of course of course yeah easy
right easy chance
this was very this was a very very
difficult very advanced level tactical
pattern but
even the way you played felix you found
a way
to make sure that the queen has to go to
g3 so you pushed f5
with the idea to push the queen down and
then you stepped away
from the g5 with the king it was very
logical because the bishop is trapped
yeah yeah um yo my pieces couldn't
breathe man i was stuck there that that
position
was true my king felt so alone look at
him look at him he's like yeah
i was pretty sure even if i trade my my
bishop i could still be winning this
activity but
well i'm not sure exactly but well i
yeah it's it's really hard to to play
this game when your your pieces are
behind
and you can't move them yeah but that
was that was my idea when i put my
my knight on on e5 if you would actually
take it i would take me with my opponent
kick your
bishop out with your night out in a way
you you couldn't you couldn't play
anymore you
your back pieces so yes that was the
idea behind the pitbull plan actually
yeah i mean uh i've been have you been
grinding the game out because you have a
pretty solid mid game
you've been playing a lot of it you've
been playing a lot of uh chess
uh i i didn't i started like two months
ago
um and i played like mostly chess for
the last two months honestly i just
played like eight hours a day
so i just yeah i'm just obsessed so yeah
i play a lot in this time yeah you
improve really fast whenever you play a
lot in one day
like uh like a lot of hours in a row i
feel like you um you know you get there
you get a lot of improvement i noticed
yeah yeah when i when i'm on something i
just dedicate my
my life into it so today is chess
tomorrow i don't know
yeah but that was some really intense
game honestly
the two of you have been on a huge grind
for the whole event as you said
xkc uh you started basically pogchamps
we we can thank
thank to you and the collaboration with
you and hikaru that
the entire chess boom started and the
the series the park champs series grew
out of that collaboration
and now you're here for your third
pogchamps unfortunately they will need
to say goodbye to you but will we see
you be back for puck chance four
yeah yeah it'll be good it'll be good uh
when i come back i'll be uh stronger
than ever and i'll
i'll take the crown then it wouldn't be
awesome to get to every match
yep okay
that has been the first of our
quarter-finals with sardos
winning and qualifying to the semifinals
we don't know his opponent yet it will
depend
on the other match as you see on that
side of the bracket we have
the quarterfinals between ludwig and
logic coming up
next that will be tomorrow but today we
still have one more clash
and that is the winner of group a
benji fishy against group b's second
place player
poker professional daniel negrano so
we're gonna have one of the best
fortnight players in the world against
poker legend daniel negranu
after a short break we'll be back with
that clash function three presented by
grip6 and the reminder on the format
because i almost forgot to mention
that in the championship bracket it's
slightly different
we have an eliminator system oh we don't
want to show the format it's it's okay i
was just reading what's on my screen the
bracket stage
consists of a single elimination system
time control is the same two games with
the time control of 10 minutes
five second increment but in case of a
tie there will be a sudden
death blitz game five minutes no
increment until someone
wins and that is indeed how the next
match will go down
as well we're gonna take a short break
and then we are back
with the quarter finals between benji
fishy and daniel negrano
against benji fishy um so i thought that
actually the two parents he could have
gotten it was
it was the best possible pairing um that
he could have had and he played really
really well
all right you guys so i'm gonna i'm
going to um go over the games now then
i'll talk more
we'll watch and i'll watch the match and
i'll talk about so e4
uh he went and i don't want to play the
second highest rate of player well
that's because benji fishy um
smokes sardo's 2-0 in their individual
match that's why
uh because benji just crushed crushed
sardos so i'm not sure that you can
actually say that sardosh is the is this
is the highest rated is he the best
player unclear
unclear all right so e4 and now here
starters play c5
uh which is the sicilian defense now
here xqc goes bishop c4 now just for
sure
um what i would say is i think that xqc
should start the
other order play knight to f3 pawn to d6
and now push the pawn on center now
regardless of the second move d6 knight
c6
whatever second move black plays even e6
they're one two three moves
you always play d4 with your next move
and actually
after pawn takes knight takes knight f6
here you can now go knight to c3
and um sargeras would have played asics
and you can play bishop c4 once again
and get the same opening
uh this is the souzan sicilian it was
the favorite of the former world chess
champion
bobby fischer so instead xcc goes bishop
c4
d6 knight f3 knight of six knights e3
pretty good stuff e6 castles bishop e7
and now he plays d4 so we end up
transposing back into the sews and
sicilian with bishop z4 as i pointed out
before this was the favor of the former
world chess champion
um bobby fischer he really loved to play
this against the night or
so a6 rookie one b5 now here
bishop b3 is a little bit preferable or
maybe pawn to or um but not not a bad
move
by any stretch so now here starters
castles
xpc goes queen f3 now again not to get
too deep into the weeds of what the
theory is here
but a better way to play this would be
to play pawn to f4 with the idea of
playing f5 and trying to rip open this
long diagonal
for your bishop and the only way to sort
of get at these two pawns here because
you can't sacrifice is to play f4 and go
f5 and just rip open this diagonal
force it open so for example let's just
say black goes bishop b7 you play pawn
to f5
and after e5 knight f3 you'll you'll
notice that this diagonal is open now
for the bishop feel a lot of scope here
um so it's very important that you try
to rip open this diagonal
because right now the the pawn sort of
on e6
it closes this diagonal since the pawn
behind it protects it so
it would have been um would have been
really really really important so
instead he goes queen f3 not a bad move
bishop b7
queen to e2 now again very hard to play
this on
the fly but probably what you should do
is play pawn to a3 to prevent this pawn
push
which removes the knight from the center
and then following that what you do is
let's say knight d7
you can now play queen g3 with multiple
ideas let's just say black plays a
random move like knight b6
you go bishop takes pawn pawn takes
bishop knight takes and not only do you
attack the queen and fork the queen the
rook but you also are threatening to go
checkmate with the queen on g7
so black would have to play something
like rook to f7 and now you just take
the queen of your way ahead
um so this would have been something
that's good let me turn on those sounds
again one second
um so so a3 would have been good and
also let's just say black was knight c5
you can now potentially play bishop h6
lining up a pin and threatening another
checkmate with the queen
and the bishop here and if black pushes
you just take a rook
so this would have been really really
good um it's a really good idea again
very very hard to find i'd say
borderline impossible if you're not
pretty advanced or you haven't studied
the opening
so it goes queen e2 b4 knight a4 knight
takes e4 very well played by sardosh
and now f3 is played here by xqc and
actually let me turn on the bar for this
as well
um so now this this again very advanced
move the computer will say
you play bishop f6 and you're much
better um
so this is this is one move that can be
good that can be played here
um and black's better you can play
knight c5 or knight f6 both moves are
also possible
um but this move is you're not going to
see this at an amateur level
it's just too hard um so here the two
moves that you consider really are
knight f6 or knight c5 now starters
plays knight c5
looks like a logical move um but after
knight c5 there's a very
strong idea which is knight takes pawn
takes and knight takes e6
and this is actually winning um because
after black recaptures knight you take
with the queen and you hit the king on
g8 but also you're gonna take the bishop
on e7 because your rook and queen are
attacking it
and if black goes rook to f7 you just
take because the bishop holds the queen
and if king h8 you just trade uh trade
on e7 and now you'll see
black has five pawns white has six pawns
and it's very easy development you just
bring the bishop and bring the rooks in
stack them and white is close to winning
here
so uh this would have been winning for
xc again very hard to find he plays a3
takes he takes for the pawn d5 is played
here by sardosh they trade
all pretty standard here and this was
probably the last critical moment that
xec had a chance in this game
uh he really needed to play this move
queen to b5 which creates a double
attack on the pawn and the bishop
again i would say i wouldn't say
impossible
but i would say extremely unlikely
without without without
being an advanced player so i think xqc
i
found knight c5 which is also a nice
move but now after rook takes sardos
to his credit finds queen to b6 a really
really good move
um and now if knight takes bishop you
just take on d4
and here again white can play queen b5
and white is actually i think a little
bit better here because even though
black is plus
one in this position you'll notice that
um is this
is this better for white or maybe not
maybe it's not actually but after knight
to d4
you'll notice that this knight on b8 is
kind of stuck and these knights on c5
and d4 are very very strong
and white has a really strong rook that
can go down to e7 or maybe eight
potentially later on so
even though black is technically up a
pawn white has very good chances here
so uh again if you don't see queen b5
and it's a very hard move
limited time um then there's not much
you can do
so now rook c1 or c8 happens queen to c2
by x you see and at this point it's
already too late because if you go queen
b5 again
now after trades i have a very nasty
move knight
[Music]
[Music]
this is only the beginning
welcome back to patreon three presented
by grip6 i hope you guys are enjoying
the show
and a reminder that this is an amazing
event with an amazing codes
our participants have chosen 16
charities
to which the donations will be going to
the charity donations from you guys
are matched by chess.com up to a hundred
thousand dollars
let's get to 25 000 today can we there's
a banner
below the video and also the link in the
chat exclamation mark donate click on
that link
and donate when you can as much as you
can
every single penny matters so there's no
such thing as too low
when it comes to supporting great causes
such as these organizations
that our participants have chosen sqc is
still keeping it mysterious
as well as sardoche but the rest of the
players have picked their charities and
i think each and every one of them
are great causes to support so make sure
to support these charities if you would
like to
join us in this cause exclamation mark
donate in the chat as well as the banner
under the video and
huge chat that by the way on that note
to reminder any currency who donated
500 euros now chess.com
there you go you need to measure that
500 and let's make jails.com
match up to a hundred thousand dollars
thank you so much to each and every one
of you for your donations
andrea what's coming up next is that we
are getting set up for our quarterfinals
but tomorrow
tomorrow we're gonna have four clashes
four clashes four games wow it's gonna
be a big day tomorrow
indeed two of the quarter-finals of the
championship bracket
and two quarter finals from the
consolation bracket
i will certainly be very
excited and worried and nervous about
the matches of my students
nico versus rubius and pocky facing myth
three of them are my students but the
other two matches too
rain wilson's against moist critical and
ludwig versus logic how do you
see those championship bracket
quarterfinals uh
going down and who do you predict making
it to the semi-finals
yeah there are so many great matchups
tomorrow but honestly
rain i think he's a monster i i love
moist but i'm scared for moist against
rain
and i think it's really cool nico versus
rubius there nico also has a huge
spanish community so i think that's a
really great matchup
um and then pokey for smith i think
pokey
might school myth a little bit i we did
do one coaching a little bit more with
pokey
maybe i'm a bit biased but um i i don't
know what do you think's happening
between ludwig and logic though
it's gonna be a very close one i feel
like ludwig has been really consistent
preparing for the tournamental
grandmaster robert has
cutie was saying they are spending maybe
a bit too much time together there's a
romans brewing in the background my
logic is taking it the
other way he's he is taking it as
freestyling vibing he doesn't want
too much preparation but wants to enjoy
the games and so far it has been working
very well for him as well so it's it's
gonna be interesting to see which one
will count
more the grind and the lessons almost
every single day on ludwig's side or
logic who has had more chest experience
but isn't
prefer isn't preparing much by match for
this event
yeah they both have put in a lot of
hours and suggests
and we have our next quarter finals
match just about to start
reminder here we've got the winner of
group a benji fishy who won every single
match of his
and his opponent is the poker legend
himself daniel negrano
who was also close to winning his group
he was leading
but then he lost his match against xqc
so group b
was a tough one it was almost
a last minute qualification by poki who
surprised
who surprised xqc and daniel as well and
took down
rubius in her match against rubius but
overall we've got sqc
and daniel negrano qualifying from group
b
go ahead these participants are very
exciting because i mean benji you've
been seeing how much he's been training
with hammer right
it's been crazy training and obviously
it's paying off
and then daniel my dad is like his
biggest fan because
we are canadian romanian and so is
daniel and my dad always watches his
streams and i was here practicing
chess so i don't know who to root for
today
oh i didn't know that papa bothers papa
wattas has been rooting for daniel the
whole time
number one fan of danielle and danielle
by the way is streaming so you guys can
check out his stream too we will be
definitely listening in
while benji usually doesn't stream
during the games but
his coach might be his coach grandmaster
young vic hammer often hosts watch
parties and they prepare for the match
every day i wonder if if there will be
any changes or surprises
when it comes to the opening repertoire
of benji he usually goes for
for a d4 opening nowadays i feel like
he's switching a little bit to those he
started out with the english opening
which is not that common on beginner
level
yeah honestly i think with hammer's prep
benji already has more opening expertise
than i do
i mean he has had so many prepared lines
it was pretty great he's certainly
picking up
on all the theoretical knowledge from
grandmaster hammer's side
for those of you who may not know that
name grandmaster you will be hammer is a
former
second of the world champion magnus
carlsen
and he is working now with benji to
prepare him for the tournament
as on the other side we've got dania who
also has taken lessons from none other
than gm hikaru
and gotham chess and i myself uh chimed
in a little bit because i felt too bad
that two of my students were out
preparing
danielle he complained that i prepared
to poke
and rubios for their matches so i helped
him
since although maybe it wasn't good
enough for her help because the match
against xqc didn't go
the way we planned it yeah excuse me
killed that match
well hey i see oh okay the game has
started
be right here okay there we go
all right so does benji typically play
this
g3 setup i can't tell this is new
something hammer has prepared
he does i was i was pulling um these
awkward faces apologies to everybody
because
i downloaded an extension today that
screams at me
every time i there's no move on the
board within the next two seconds
uh hikaru and gotham chest start
screaming at you to make a move
so it's it's currently on in my browser
and
then i started listening to hikaru
saying move just move just make a move
and i was wondering is this part of our
broadcast but then i realized no no anna
you
you are again moving booming
extension but it's a great one it's a
great extension just don't use it during
broadcast
as far as the g3 setup goes yes benji
does like
the fiance setup and play for the
catalan structure in this case so
started that with english
now it's more of a catalan that he's
aiming for
but we could transpose to even e4
openings if benji pushes the
pawn to e4 later that could be more like
a sicilian
dragon or a night or daniel does play
the sicilian with the black pieces
against e4
yeah let's be comfortable i i was gonna
ask
i've never seen someone who plays a neck
pillow while streaming and playing chess
i think that's a pretty good idea true
it's a new thing for me but
i i definitely would need it sometimes
and i'm like oh this is this is too
stiff
and yeah whoa okay i can make it more
cozy
a trade on c6 what do you think of this
andrea after bish
after b takes c6 the bishop is pointing
at the c6 bomb but the queen is guarding
it from d7
yeah he he took very fast i was a little
bit questionable about
daniel's queen b7 move and normally you
don't want to block your bishop so early
but
i don't think taking was very good for
benji because it brings the pawns
together and
when i play the sicilian and sometimes
we can use the a6 or the b7 square in
this case
but so comfortable play for white what
do you think anna
i think it's comfortable but it's also
gonna be
all right for black if he if he now
speeds up with the development
i think g6 bishop g7 crossover kingside
would be a way to go bishop b7 is
logical too to guard the pawn and maybe
later push
c5 yeah both will be on shadow play here
i was curious why do you think he played
queen d7 so early on
good question um in that structure
of if we go back just a few moves where
he decided to play just trying to defend
yes the knight was hanging but you're
right that usually the queen goes to
c7 or b6 those are more natural squares
because the queen on d7 is blocking the
bishop but overall i think it worked out
well for daniel because after the trade
the b pawn is now on c6 so the bishop
does have the b7 square
i think his development will be all
right if he goes for
g6 bishop to g7 on the other flank or
pushing the e pawn and bishop e7
yeah now he has no issue blocking his
bishop
so far i always i don't really like to
play these double fiance positions
because i feel like they're they're just
so repetitive and there's not much
happening but
on the right side you don't spend too
much time wearing in your opening
and it's a very solid setup a classical
approach i think if banjo pushes later
the pawn to e4 he will be expanding even
further in the center
c5 by daniel i do like that move to
offer the trade of bishops
let's see if banji will take it or
perhaps push e4 to block the diagonal
but overall now the light squared bishop
of black
is a lot more active since the diagonal
is open
yeah and he's doing the right thing
because you normally want to trade
the bishop that's defending the king
here so this fianchetto bishop is more
important than this one since we can
castle king side
there's a nice move c5
i like it a lot and i'm wondering if
we're gonna see e4
instead of e4 knight to d5 that's an
interesting response to
to trade on the d5 square i wonder if
danielle will capture that knight with
either his knight or the bishop
usually when there's a choice you take
first with the knight and then after
bishop takes d5 you could have taken the
bishop two but pawn takes d5
now means that the light squared bishops
will not be traded and i think it's time
to develop the king's side so let's see
if daniel is on the same page
and pushes g6 to friend cato the other
bishop make it
to g7 and castle kingside gosling here
i think is becoming urgent and so he
goes for g6
yeah it's a very interesting position
they traded all their miners except the
bishop pair
um i think benji might be able to get a
little bit of space
in the center but these bishops these
or whenever i mean if they keep the
bishops it could be a little bit rash
i wonder how it's going to unravel from
here i'm curious how will benji
follow up this plan now with the pawn
structure being
somewhat different to the usual setups
that he goes for
and uh now that he can't really go for
b3 bishop d2
or at least it wouldn't be the same to
try to fianchetto
yeah bishop g7 of course yes now you can
no longer
follow the double fianchetto i mean
maybe he could prepare it with rook b1
but
his bishop has a lot of good scores on
this diagonal as well
i agree and then just taking his time to
come up with the right setup
i think it's it's definitely a key
moment
because you need to decide where do you
want to place this c1 bishop
will you try to place it on the long
diagonal bishop d2 bishop c3 would be an
option for that too
or bishop f4 to keep it on the h61
diagonal
but now after bishop g7 um the b2 pawn
two is targeted i think this bishop will
be very powerful on the long diagonals
there was
i was leaning toward bishop d2 bishop c3
to try to challenge this bishop and not
let it be
a power piece yeah here i mean typically
okay and he plays i was going to say
well black has a really strong bishop
maybe he could try to trade it on h6
and he is going for that which is always
so annoying when i play the fiance
bishop on the king side
i don't like the bishop h6 lines i agree
with you and let's listen a bit daniel
if he's any worried about those bishop
trades or not
get situated get safe and then
i think i gotta push this epon at some
point right
that e point what's this now okay i'm
not going to
take so he's trying to come here with
the queen
nope i'm not going to let that happen so
we are going to
protect this square even more
with this and then we trade here but our
king is still protected
so far i'm playing well i haven't made
any mistakes as far as i know like i've
made mistakes i'm sure but like
for my game and where it's at
happy with the start so far now you just
got to focus
he takes ends to take
okay now what do we do now what do we do
i don't really know
but
we seem safe right okay what's that now
he's coming to press that
pressure that pawn okay so he could on
facant me
if i push up there twice so he's coming
well what's that going to do
anything that's an
important detail if we bring our board
back andrea the umpire son
rule a reminder to our viewers engaged
they haven't heard of that strange thing
called amphison
that it's a thing it doesn't happen too
often but if you push your phone two
squares
and there's this d5 phone that could
jump capture you
it captures in passing on vassan
it takes on e6 and that would attack the
queen as well as opens up the long
diagonals so if you capture
the pawn with the queen your b7 bishop
falls
yes i learned when we uh hosted block
champs we forgot to teach
one of our participants what it was and
he was very shocked when
the pawn took not now as it normally
does so
i'm glad he's aware of it yeah um
it can look like a glitch because you
have a pod on e5 and suddenly it's gone
yeah is a special rule has it can only
happen though if the pawn
jumps two squares jumps across the
capture square of the other pawn
an ampersand is only possible straight
away right after the move was played you
cannot make it a move later
then it's already not available it's
going to be illegal to
try to capture the pronunciation v8 i
like
and then what do you think for sure
because you can carry
it a lot it's very nice the two rooks
like you said there was a lot of tactics
and he couldn't push
and he needs to break through because
his bishop would be hanging and now he
defended both squares so
eventually maybe he can push that pawn
the only issue with his unpleasant idea
that he sees that there will be another
sound that's good
but the next thing to see that after you
push the e pawn the d6 pawn becomes more
vulnerable
so even if he's not losing the bishop on
b7 e5
d takes e6 the d6 pawn uh could be an
issue
and it's happening let's see if angie
captures the pawn or not so he has a
choice you don't have to do the opposite
capture you have a choice
but only now only here and now if banji
plays anything else
he can no longer do it and he does he
does take the pawn
meaning that now daniel has to be
careful to remember that the d6 pawn has
become
exposed now through the d5 where benji's
queen and rook are lined up so he has to
take back on e6 little rook to guard the
pawn
yeah i don't think it's too bad if he
takes with the rook i mean
luckily maybe he could unpin his queen
and since the queen is attacking the
pawn first but
it is a backwards pawn and it is a big
weakness for daniel
i think he did the right thing with rook
takes e6 he must have seen this coming
so i think he calculated that this will
happen
and by by trading the d5 pawn at least
there's no longer upon
that suffocating your pieces that yes it
was annoying taking a lot of space away
from black's pieces so overall i think
this was a good idea
to free black's pieces and we're going
to see a heavy psm game only rooks and
queens on the board
yeah it's going to be they traded very
quickly in this game oh but
benji does not want to trade he wants to
leave the bishops on the board
yeah what do you think about his move i
think it's a tricky one i think i see
what he wants
i think he spotted that the rook on e6
and the queen on d7 are on the same
diagonal and bishop to h3
could win one of those pieces wow you
think he's going for the tactics
i think so i think he's very sharp that
one
would that'd be impressive i think of
that trick i i feel like he's setting
it up because he blocks the long
diagonal so after bishop h3
queen c6 will no longer be attacking
anything around the king
without this so if he had moved bishop
to h3 a move earlier
if we if we just show for a moment um
it wouldn't have been that powerful
first of all um
queen to c6 threatens checkmate on h1
or g3 if the bishop moves away and even
f5 could have happened
um i think it's happening actually
andrew we need to go back check it out
go go
don't do it because it's how he plays it
bishop wow benji is very sharp he had a
slim
which i think it was interesting to kind
of put this pawn in the center create a
potential weakness and go for this but
daniel didn't see it he did not
see it and he was clearly showing
signs of shock he grabbed his head
and he missed this idea we need to see
now
how will he try to save the situation
the rook will be lost you cannot move it
because then it's even worse
and then his pawn is gonna be hanging
he's gonna have to be doing a lot of
defending
yeah just get max value and take the
pawn oh no i can't take the pawn because
then he just takes
off oh good job dude you really got me
good with this
i don't know i don't know
i've never heard that phrase
benji i did not see he's right though he
needs to get max value for the road
up my rook and queen
good job he's good all right we are
definitely behind
[ __ ] but we're not out we're not gonna
quit
hm do our best
this
[Music]
i'll have to look at it later okay and
this is an
obvious move here
so he's up two points i got one pawn
back so listen it's not the end of the
race
he lost a piece but what do i do now i
think
come up the left side with the pawns and
the king
he's so well protected
all right
[Music]
looks like we're coming for a battle
shortly
f3 is a great move by benji to
strengthen the central pawn on e4
yes very solid it doesn't want to give
daniel any counter play here
and now g5 by daniel to try to tear
those phones apart i think he is trying
to push at some point for now it's
making
it's making the structure a bit more
fixed i wonder if he actually wants to
push g4 or it's simply
making his king side feel safer it's
tough to play this position
because he did lose the rook on e6 at
the same time the position is still
very closed and rooks love open files so
banji will need to try to
open up the position yeah that's very
true i mean he's a material but
the plan for white to break through
isn't clear like i i think daniel can
just kind of wait
i agree with you and i wonder if this is
what
he's explaining he really is truly in
the midst of his thought process and
going here and there explaining it to
his audience
queen to c2 by benji let's listen in i'm
curious if that's what daddy i was
talking about
g6 by moving your pawn up
attack attack i think i need to move my
king where does my king go in a more
protected spot
yeah king's gotta go
here i wanna say oh wait yeah i know
here's fine oh no
is it fine i think back actually
not sure clearly
do not know now that pawn is vault no
it's not vulnerable because my queen's
protecting it
i think i expect the pawn push from him
soon
with that e5 square i can take back with
my pawn all right he's breaking up my
chain
hmm if we bring our analysis
back for a moment there are possibly
tactics in this position because of the
king stepping away it was an interesting
decision by daniel i didn't know if it
was needed but now he is taking on f4
and the g file is opening up so actually
his move becomes even stronger now that
the king is on f8
the g5 is available for black's pieces
and i was wondering if he could have
taken on e4 but he plays queen to g7
instead a lot more logical
king f2 and will we see
will we see a pawn sacrifice because if
you push f5 and white takes it queen to
g2 would be
check me wow i wonder if he will try
to do it dad has been talking about f5
for the last five moves or like yeah and
it was always wrong but it's finally
finally it's moments time to shine here
f5 would be very
very nice okay it's logical
very logical too yeah attacking f4
threatening queen age for check i think
daniel is back in the game because of
the activity of his queen and how this
bishop on c6
can become the hero of the story if he
finds the right moment to push f5
yeah this pawn structure is so fragile i
mean he has to keep his queen and his
rook to defend everything
i don't even know what he can bring in
to defend these dark squares
not an easy one for benji if he wants to
hold on to the pawn on f4 he will need
to protect it with a move like
queen to d2 yep and then the pawn will
be hanging
on e4 which is is even more dangerous
i i honestly i'm not sure what's the
best defense here for white
i feel like you will need to give up the
f4 pawn and try to bring your queen
to the king side let's save it like
and queen f3 afterwards but you are
giving up a lot of pawns
um and it's never an easy decision to
take because of course you always want
to try to defend everything that's
hanging in this case i think banji needs
to
think of damage control and realize that
if he wants to hold on to the f4 pawn
perhaps he's losing more than the pawn
yeah this this got so tricky i mean
currently it's a dead draw but
even like the solid defense that you put
i think the okay
they would still be losing the e4 pawn
here
he plays queen 2d2 and this is a moment
where where
black could take awning for with the
bishop
yes threaten queen f3 or queen to g2
um maybe in that position white
should give up the rook for the bishop
rook takes 36
and then at least he can take the d6
phone too both kings will be exposed
yeah this i don't even know
let's play let's look at this position
here um
both both sides can really check
anywhere they want but
i don't think i don't think white has a
specific plan here
this this would be this would be perhaps
still anyone's game i need to
happen it may have been drawn
all right it may happen because daniel
has taken
on e4 so now it's up to benji whether he
realizes the danger of this light
squared bishop
and gives up his rook for the bishop
will he do it
or will he try to defend by playing
i don't know rook g1 looks like it could
defend something but then queen f3 and
bishop discovered czech i think
his only move is to give up wow
will he see it he's got two minutes two
minutes left
to decide about that sacrifice if he
doesn't do it
i think his king will be checkmated in a
few moves
it is option defense
wow he started with some very sharp
tactics but it's just this one move and
from there the game took a turn now it'd
be very interesting to go into the
the end game with just rook and queen
i wonder if it will come to that
conclusion because any other attempt i
feel like will be
way too dangerous for the king again the
threats of black are the ones marked by
andrea queen f3 and queen g2 and then a
discovery check on the e
file you could look at so if white tries
to defend mate here then
queen f3 and now this is the discovery
attack you were talking about anna
indeed and after king to e1 it's gonna
be made
almost wherever the bishop goes bishop
d3 perhaps he's the most precise just to
finish the game on the spot but the king
can't brutal
okay so he literally has no choice but
to stack let's see
oh my god he's under a minute even with
if he does sack
going to an end game with equal material
but this big
time disadvantage it's going to be very
hard for him to play under pressure
and he played it he played it rook takes
e4 by
benji fishy with one minute left on the
clock he plays the only
move that can save his king and now
after rook takes e4
the queen can take the d pawn and
suddenly both kings will be vulnerable
yeah this is such a weird position i
mean black is trying to take on f4
white could just check and try to
potentially escape
it's gonna be very interesting all right
oh they played it
it's happening it's happening rook takes
c4 queen takes d6
let's see where danya goes with the king
he chooses the g7 square oh
the queen trade if banjo wants he could
trade with queen d7
am i seeing i must have been this the
rookie one must have not worked
oh yeah because rook takes you were
right that didn't look no no it didn't
work it didn't work
it looked like about this gambit but it
wasn't a full one because of rick takes
there for winning the rogue but the
the rook trade rook shade not but the
queen trade is happening on d7 so queen
d7 was played by benji trade on d7
and king g6 king f3
oh wow from a position where white was
about to be mated benji realized he had
to give the material back and we are
seeing
currently a rook end game with equal
material
benji is taking the a7 pawn so he does
have now an extra pawn can dania fight
back
attack maybe the h pawn uh or
maybe maybe activate his king but the
problem with activating the king is that
the h7 pawn two will be hanging
wow and both players know the stats here
you always want to bring the rooks
behind the pawns
what daniel is doing but i mean he has
this password i don't think he'll be
able to stop
it after king to g3 h5
a4 is a very logical decision to run
with the passport but that creates a
weakness
in the structure the b3 pawn and
danielle immediately spots it attacks it
with rook to b1
i'm expecting rook b7 by benji no he
plays rookies
attacking it but he get the check
check it's taken with the check
unfortunately for
benji he may not have seen that he was
going to be captured with a check and
now
dania could attack both the a and f
phones with root b4
oh my god but it's still well according
to evaluation still
draw here oh i think it may be cool but
it doesn't matter but it doesn't eat
anyone's game it's not anyone's game
rook end games are my least favorite
they're so tricky
are they okay he's going all right he's
not defending his f4 pawn he's trying to
push
danya takes first and f4 and i think now
he will go to the a fight to stop the
passport rook to a4
that's my prediction he has to stop that
pawn before it's too late
so rook a4 a7 and then there's no way
that white can
defend this a8 square without moving his
rook
so can't promote just yet
rookie four played by daniel and a7
immediately by benji
now c4 so the point is that with this
defense the tara shrook we call it this
a4 rook for black it means that
you can't move the rook away from the
seventh rank because our
our rook is well positioned to capture
the pawn as soon as you try to support
the promotions grab it rook c8
the pawn on a7 will drop so it's a great
great resource that daniel has found
it's exactly how it's written in the end
game textbooks
and he's pushing his his past pawn his
upper pawn and he could also try
to bring his king closer or push the f
pawn
i think benji should be able to hold it
under i don't circumvent
it he has taken a beautiful
game so far wow he takes a c4 because if
danielle ever gonna take
the rook on c4 the phone could have
promoted so
very nice tactic on what they found by
benji simplifying the position the less
pawns the better in this rook end game
for the defense
now this f pawn shouldn't be winning but
danya can try
and i think on this level you still need
to be very careful
rook czech king coming closer white has
to defend precisely
what do you think is there any plan
where black can try to use their extra
pawn here
to win if you trade and you plan to
break
yeah if you traded rooks in the right
moment on the right spot for instance
that would be one of the dangers the
king and poland game
funnily enough f and h pawns in rook and
games can also be drawn with that white
having an age pawn but those are
very specific positions and i don't
think uh we're gonna get to see that h3
i feel like
benji is sammy setting up a stalemate
yeah he's trying i don't know
he could have forced it with a rook
check he's escaped though
king back to g3 i wonder if daniel will
start bringing his
king he plays rook to e5
okay so now what maybe king g5
trying to advance running a check
but even okay he's preventing it let's
listen to him and what he thinks about
this rookhand game and he's winning
chances
trade the rook and then run the pawn up
somehow
he's got 18 seconds tick-tock baby
oh wow that was
not good from him oh is it
maybe it is good hold on oh my
god i think we need our board back
through the drawers
oh my god he just had to take the rook
taking the rook here
but it was it was going to be another
end game you take this pawn and even if
black wins h4 it would have been a draw
but now black is winning
this is a winning king and pawning game
and i think daniel knows it we shall see
his king and
technique but i think he knows it that
banji made a mistake
allowing the rook trade the way it
happened in the game is exactly what he
should have prevented
yeah i mean the draw was like a slip of
his fingers
but now this is why when my dad trained
me always taught me that end games
matter most important at beginner level
because if you know how to trade
everything you know your end game is
better
but here daniel did not know his end
games well
i guess both sides banji banjo didn't
know that's true yourself with the rook
train
no one knew their end game well
now this is a winning king and born in
game very simply winning by pushing the
pawn to
f2 but daniel may have gotten scared of
a ghost stalemate coming back
we do it again yeah he could
hopefully he doesn't want to trade his
f1 for the h pawn
that would that would be a disaster
in this way it's fine if you don't lose
your f1 then it's fine
wow
so all right here we go again here we go
again
and now both the age and f phones are
running so white
cannot prevent the promotion of both
pawns daniel could claim
two queens if he wants he can promote
both of those pawns and give a checkmate
with two queens on the board and why not
have to
check f1 queen next move
let's look at the game what a game
let's listen to daniel what he says two
queens
nice and easy and then we walk him back
oh baby doll so calm we got him people
we done did it
up one with black too
i love his phrases he's like a nice dad
at a barbecue or something with the
first game
dean eggs is on the board whoo
baby doll how the hell did i do that
winning the first game of his
quarterfinals against
the favorite one would have thought
benji fishy won all of his
matches in the group stage and now he
will be in a must-win situation
when we return for the second game andra
your thoughts on this roller coaster and
what happened with benji
first winning on exchange but then
danielle fighting back with that
kingside attack it was honestly such a
high level game it was a beautiful game
like down in exchange he managed to get
the king attack win this end game like
doesn't look like a pogchamp game to me
what are you thinking
very high level fight with both of them
playing i think
really precisely there were a few
mistakes and the final one being benji
allowing the rook trade in a way that
the king and opponent game was
unfortunately for him a theoretical loss
so maybe his coach will talk to him more
about king and phone and games too
we're gonna listen to his stream while
we take a short break
pogchamps three presented by grip six we
will be back in a moment
um and here in this position
he did have the opportunity to exchange
after which it would have been a draw
but instead he chose to do the exchange
under
unfavorable circumstances because here
black has this extra pawn and there's
nothing you can do to stop that pawn
from going up the board and becoming a
new queen
is something like king g2 a lot better
where he pushed the pawn um
i mean anything is really better than
what he did
uh but the plan we were studying was
that he could try and get his rooks
together
uh working towards this pawn on d6
so that was like he the reason benji
pushed this pawn forward was because he
wasn't sure
what to do next but one of the things he
could have done was putting pressure
down down towards the the black pawn
can you call benji i'm not calling benji
but i will say that
i'll send him a message
do
are you benji's coach yes so i've been
coaching benji
every single day uh for the last
month and uh a half honestly
a month and a half we've been working
now and benji has made
tremendous tremendous progress
uh and now next game he's gonna play the
french opening
and if you want to know how benji is
going to play this french opening
you can actually check it out on my
youtube channel
because i i published there a video
on on how benji will play
with the with the black pieces
it's uh benji's favorite opening to play
the french honestly
he prefers being black to being white
so there's no reason to give up just yet
he will get another chance
don't spoil for daniel well if daniel
has seen it then
you know good for him
he's done his research but i i think and
this is my opinion
i think benji's opening is so good
that even if daniel has watched
uh our videos our coaching every every
coaching session i've had with benji
i i've streamed on my channel
so anyone can go into my video library
and watch the lessons we've had
including the lesson
on the french which is what benji will
uh
we'll we'll go for now
revealing your proteges openings what
are you
the saint louis chess club no i
i i'm just saying there's there's good
there's a good opening for beginners
hey me again luscious larry leather
browns
sweaty heavy pocky leather wow
mom wait don't kiss him i'm your son i'm
here from the future
if you kiss him i won't exist so please
hey i love your belt is that what you
wear in the future
rad totally what my grip 6 belt i know
right i love this no flailing flaps
bulging buckles they're
hideous holes and with a lifetime
guarantee you really can't go
whether it's the grip six belts or the
chest that you are aiming to get we hope
that you already visited the website
at go dot chess dot com slash grip six
but
big news an update from grip six is that
they have restocked their chess wallets
as well so if you want to get the chest
wallet
that was previously sold out they now
have another 50 units added to their
stock at this time
make sure to take advantage of it and
use the code pogchamps
20 to get 20 percent off again it's
go.js.com
grip6 well anna that was a very exciting
game
do you think what are the chances we go
into a sudden death
i think the chances are still pretty
good for benji from what we have heard
from his coach grandmaster joel vic
hammer
is that benji actually prefers to play
with the black pieces
that he loves the french defense so much
i fully agree and approve
that he likes to play a lot that system
and now he will have
a chance because danielle does play e4
with the white pieces so
we're gonna see a french defense that's
almost guaranteed
yeah i always love when coach hammer
chimes in he helps my sister a little
bit with her french defense and it
definitely paid off
but i always tell her to stop playing it
because here we struggle but with
hammer's help
i i think the french is good
and i think we have a lift off if we
update our board
daniel negrano with the white pieces he
won his first game
so benji isn't a must-win situation they
are blitzing out the initial moves
it was this capture on move three
that uh benji has gone for taking on e4
and then developing the knights
they're blitzing out these moves both of
them said you know they're very prepared
very well prepared indeed andrea this is
a theoretical line
i'm impressed grandmasters played this
park shows participants play this
they all know exactly what's the
trending move was the trending line to
go for bishop to g5
pins the knight on f6 the idea is that
the bishop cannot be taken because that
would have been a bonus gambit
too many voters can't beat no both says
gambit so yeah
they sure like their bishop positions
once again almost i guess we still have
a knight here but
benji has the bishop pair the hammer
loves bishop pear i also know that one
as well
exactly i was gonna say that on on this
account i think i
i'm thinking that the trade after bishop
takes bishop takes i do like that daniel
is going for it very confidently and
playing queen d3 so
he did give up the pair of bishops but
he does have more space
and he's ahead in development i was even
wondering whether he wanted to castle
queenside after queen d3 it would have
been an interesting choice
maybe not the best but it would have
been definitely an aggressive one he
doesn't need to be aggressive though the
match situation
is again that banji has to win
if he doesn't win this game there's no
tie breaker banji will be eliminated
from the tournament
and doesn't the french tend to get into
drawing positions and he
he can't afford a drawing a draw either
and john what are you saying about the
phrase
i mean i don't know that's what i've
heard
but maybe you've got a point maybe a
bias
may have a point but this position is
not symmetrical
the exchange variation would have been
perhaps then um a better choice for the
the drewish lines but i i like that
daniel is going for something
that's ambitious i think it's very
difficult to play for a draw
even if you know that that's a good
result for you to play
on purpose in a way that you just try to
trade and
enter a symmetrical or drawish position
is very difficult
at pogchamps level even more so a super
tournament i think grandmasters have a
repertoire
where if you need a draw you play your
more solid lines
but at park jumps even the armageddon
for tiebreakers i think rain wilson had
a good point about it that
draw odds for black is isn't really an
advantage because
there are barely any draws in this
tournament yeah i totally agree
so so here what how do you think benji
is gonna develop
i mean one interesting thing is it kind
of looks like he could transpose into
maybe
fianchetto development okay sticking out
his queen but i was gonna ask where do
you suggest
taking out the c8 bishop that's what i
don't like about the french
where you take that guy out i don't
understand it's always the problem piece
in the french you are right andra
and again it's similar because this
bishop on e4 is very annoying if you
place
the black bishop on d7 the b7 pawn will
be hanging so
yeah i mean just compare it compare this
bishop to
this bishop this is why i tell alex not
to play
the french but whatever but what about
not developing it for now because
daniel is allowing the trade on e5 so
banji could
win a pawn by capturing the knight on e5
pawn takes back and queen takes e5 i
wonder if daniel had seen this let's
listen in if he's giving up that pawn on
purpose
for now we will not know let's see if he
realizes that
straight on e5 is push potential issue
it's the f5 i'm not sure if i'm supposed
to push f4 g4
after
f4 would strengthen the night but he may
have had to do it to move
earlier if banji realizes that he can
take
taking his time at this position
understandably so
oh and we got it yeah you didn't
question what queen d6 was doing
he did not he pushed c3 to strengthen
the d4 pawn and i wonder what will be
his reaction now when
benji takes the opponent from fighting
queen troy is coming okay so a pretty
simplified position now no
if he trades if he doesn't i don't know
he did not
okay so
so in that case i think i pawn push
put more pressure on him yeah
free up the space for my rook to come
out and play
yeah he didn't even react to the fun
okay he knows good thing i put that pawn
on c3 that really helped a lot
because if i didn't then i'd be
vulnerable let's bring her
back because it it doesn't look like
danielle likes the position
i i think you're gonna need he didn't
care about that
it may be the fact that he absolutely
likes gambits
at chess many of his openings initially
for park gems
ii and pre-park gyms wear gambits he
loves the danish gambit
he learned the smiths more again with
from hikaru and he also learned a couple
of gambits with the black pieces i
wonder is it because his intuition is
saying
danielle you should have enough
conversation your pieces are active and
you have
this initiative going on the king side
so maybe even though he didn't realize
that he
lost a pawn during those trades on e5
he it's true that he is ahead in
development and the c8 bishop is still
difficult to get out of the the back
rank you cannot push the big phone do
you think he likes these gametes because
he's a poker player because he's a
gambler
i'm not sure we'll need to ask him we'll
need to ask him in the interview
if he chose gambits for that reason but
i do know that he loves
aggressive attacking chess so he doesn't
mind giving up a pawn or two if it means
that he's gonna have the upper hand and
initiative
and whether it was on purpose or not
that's what is happening partially
that he is trying to attack on the
king's side by black is still struggling
to develop
the only issue that he has pushed the f
pawn that
now for instance black could play bishop
to d7 and the b7 pawn is no longer
hanging because of queen b6 check
picking up the bishop on b7 yeah he kind
of created a weakness on this diagonal
which
he had the right ideas trying to get
space put his pawns on black because we
have the light squared bishops but
i do not like the diagonal his kings
well i guess black is
kind of in the same situation now
interesting that banji moved to g7 i
guess he didn't like if the white queen
appears on 86
yeah which which can be scary but i mean
without the dark square bishop there's
no way that white can actually ever come
to g7
he's got a point though that if white
manages to bring the rook over to the
king size
through the third rank rook to d3 or
rook f3 and then swing over to the h5
it could be troublesome that kingside
attack that could lead to checkmate yeah
that was his plan he pushed f4 with the
idea for a rook lift
i think so too you're right that this is
very dangerous here
even if he loses a second bomb because
now after queen b6 check
if the king moves to age 1 you can take
on b2 as well but
i'm worried that even though black will
be two pawns up
again there is some initiative on the
king side already and as soon as the
rooks will appear
in the attack i think in a on a
practical level it's not
easy rook to d4 though is a boundary
because the rook is pinned and the white
the white rook will not be able to
i'm not gonna lie i stared at this i was
like but after it takes
time how is it winning it was i didn't
see the queen
but i see it now i see it
[Laughter]
oh good job all right don't quit don't
quit
keep playing you've got some stuff
happening in this reaction
but it wouldn't have been a day hosted
by andrea
if we don't see him right andra it's
it's all for you
it's all in honor of you i
why would i do that all right my brain
is melted
looks like most like an armageddon but
you know what don't quit
that was just really not a didn't move
his pep talk is bad it is true maybe
like you get tilt
like in poker you get tilt when
something goes bad and then here
you know i lose my queen and i'm like oh
duh you just take his bishop i'm on tilt
now where does his bishop go it goes
wherever it wants to go
okay i was saying so true it's so true
saying let's bring the board back for a
moment to just
take in what happened rook to d4 was a
blunder if we roll back a few moves
that's when we started screaming and we
couldn't actually vocalize what went
wrong
e5 is a winning move that was spotted
instantly by banji
the bishop is attacking the queen and
the pawn is targeting the rook you will
lose either your queen
or the rook you cannot save both pieces
i have to say though the way
i really respect how his mentality like
when i get tilted
it does not end well but he's doing so
well just pep talking himself
he recognizes that he's keeping himself
positive
he's trying his best but the position
is gonna be very rough to try to hold
when it comes to
having a queen down he doesn't even have
a piece for it so it's a queen
or for no material he does have some
activity but i think benji will go for
the trades rook d8
the d4 rook is still pinned
i mean i've come back from a few solid
games after a whole queen i dropped
but i mean luckily for this we'll get a
very exciting blitz
game exactly if benji wins this game and
it seems to be
the way the game is going then there
will be a tiebreaker of a
sudden death blitz game five minutes
no increment yeah piano and unfinished
king there
uh queen's coming for the back rank
so who do you think's d4 we'll have the
upper hand in the blitz playoff
i'm not sure because i thought this
match was going very well for daniel
even this game
until rook d4 i thought white had it
under control they were saying that he
does have compensation for the pawn even
two pawns if he moved king gage1 or or
rook f2 rook ft would have guarded the
b2 pawn but rook d4 unfortunately was
a big blunder so nabanji is back in the
match
and he will have some of the
psychological advantage because he is
the one who made a huge comeback from a
match situation that was lost for him
that is true yeah well this game is
pretty much over but daniel's gonna play
until the end
oh you know anything can happen maybe i
mean at this level i don't think
you should be resigning these positions
just yet
yeah i always tell everyone i always
tell my all my bookchum students to
to never give up i know this is this is
very desperate
and benji is going for the kill queen
takes g2
is the threat checkmate and i think
we're gonna see it on the board
but at least at least he tried as much
as he could with that benji fish is
tying the score and we're gonna see our
first sudden death
blitz tiebreaker in just a few moments
andra your thoughts on this comeback i'm
very excited honestly
anything can happen in this splits we
got a botez gambit
daniel had a huge comeback in both games
even when he's losing
he comes back very well but i don't know
how they're going to perform under time
pressure
i think we started following another
norwegians game in the meantime
that's possibly because we're going to
be tuning into grand master junovic
hammer stream
for the next few minutes and then we are
back with the tiebreaker remember
this is it the quarterfinals in the
championship record
between benji fishy and daniel negranu
going down
the wire five minute sudden death blitz
games until one of them wins
see you soon in a moment functions
represented by group six
to the middle this is what we're going
for
just solid solid play get
both bishops pointing down the board
good control over the middle good
chances to win
benji is the better player he made a
mistake
in the first white game and he got
punished for it
he also freaked out when he was low on
time
but he can make the comeback
uh we've practiced the three plus one
so we've practiced uh for this tiebreak
situation
unfortunately we practiced before they
changed the rules
so instead of a brits game three plus
one
uh one second increment per move we're
now going to be playing
at five plus nil uh and so benji
is not very comfortable without the
increments
i think so that's gonna be a big change
for him
uh okay so benji has acknowledged that
he got my message
and he has said he will not take this
knight
otherwise we're not changing the opening
we were happy with the white opening
last time my main concern right now
is pacing pacing is really difficult
especially when you've just played a 10
minute game
where you in addition got five extra
seconds per move that was made
it's very different changing into
a game without increment and with less
time it's difficult to make that
mental adjustment has benji played a lot
of blitz
asks andy uh not a lot but
we have specifically practiced to play
um bullet chests and uh three minute
chests
to get better at dealing with
stressful situations when you're low on
time and the reason we did that
is because we knew that there could be
tie breaks
in the knockout stages and you need to
be ready for that
so we definitely trained for the tie
breaks
but unfortunately we didn't practice uh
five minute games
uh no mike it's not an armageddon
it's not an armageddon it's five minutes
for both players
if it's a draw they play another game
it's so hard with no increment and time
becomes way more tactical
yes at tizer which is why you know
i wish we could have practiced the new
rules
but segavi
negranu might revert to the danish
gambit with a lower time
no he you cannot play the danish gambit
against the french i'm sorry it's just
not possible
i i don't care how fond you are of his
danish gambit
it's not gonna happen today i'm sorry
benji plays the french defense
very solid opening choice in fact i
think
everyone starting out in chess should
play the french defense because
it it stops all of these tricky openings
in fact i think it's the safest opening
for a beginner
to learn which is why i've made a
youtube video
named the safe
welcome back to the broadcast of
function 3 presented by grip6 we will
have our first
tiebreaker in the championship bracket
and a reminder on the format that this
is going to be
a sudden death blitz game five minutes
no increment both players will have five
minutes with no increment
and the player who wins will move on to
the semi-finals in case of a draw
we're gonna have a next sudden death
blitz games and the next one and the
next one
until one of the players manages to win
and qualify
to the semis andra your thoughts on the
tiebreaker
after hearing that benji's coach
gm hammer said that benji may not have
practiced much of a bliss
yeah amber did say he doesn't play a lot
with
increment but honestly i kind of feel
like
my prediction is we might get a draw
which is fun the more blitz the better
but i i don't know how much experience
um daniel has without increments
i was taking a look at their accounts in
terms of blitz games i'm not sure about
whether with increment or not but
danielle does have
more blitz games let's see okay i was
going to mention
real quick that danielle has played over
900 blitz games and benji
36 blitz games wow clearly more
experience on daniel's side but maybe
maybe not without increments so let's
see how this game will turn out
similar opening as in the first game
benji with the white pieces since he
is number one seated in group a
therefore he receives the white pieces
daniel has been a chess fan for very
long but 900 games is a lot of blitz i
must say
pretty great very true let's see how
benji deals with this new situation that
he needs to play a blitz tiebreaker with
absolutely no increment so there's
there's zero increment it's not the same
when it comes to time pressure
with the the rapid format e5 here
by daniel what do you think of this push
andrea um well before
e5 i was gonna say he fixed his mistake
because in the previous game he played
queen d7 which blocked his bishop oh i
guess
this knight before line's actually a
little bit annoying but
he played differently from the first
game because he analyzed his games
it's true that he learned from that uh
slightly misplaced queen on d7 but now
it's
nice b5 especially since he pushed e5 to
chase that
away yeah i think we needed like an a6
or something i
i'm not sure but he can still
yeah indeed he can still go for it he
can still push a6 and then the knight
has to go to a3 since this other knight
is occupying the c3 square
yup he just took his square knight on
the rim
it i always say is slim but it's dim i
just learned uh
recently actually i think both are cute
both are adorable and both certainly
mean that it's not the best not the
coolest something
has to be played there's so many words
that work
whatever okay
we need to see how daniel will develop
his pieces i think bishop b7
is a very logical move and he's ready to
castle next the only
issue with his spawn structure is that
the d6 pawn is a backward pawn and it
can be a future target as well as the d5
square is a weakness
so overall even though banjo's knight is
on the edge of the board
if he brings it back through a night
maneuver like knight to c to knight e3
then knight d5 he would have a better
position so let's see if he will
if he'll realize that he shouldn't leave
the knight on a3 and maneuver it back
toward the middle of the board
yeah that maneuver would be beautiful to
see which makes a lot of sense because
he doesn't really have any other squares
and normally you're suggesting for benji
earlier in the last game
which is e4 pawn but here do you still
think he should be pushing in the center
i think for now it's great that the
bishop has an open diagonal and puts so
much pressure on black's pieces so
i think it's fine to not push e4 since
he still has his c4 pawn two
guarding the d5 square knight to g4
by daniel i was curious if he was gonna
move the queen away because he has to
get that bishop out of the background
somehow
yep same problem as last time maybe
he'll do the same
development on b7 but i'm not sure
his knight g4 move i i mean it gets
kicked away in
one move and then you have to retreat
but okay he didn't push h3 anyway
let's listen him with him and see if he
sees the knight form that is being
threatened on b6
freaking face and i hate it all right
we're going back i'm getting rid of that
see that's stupid right anytime you do
that you know you don't know what you're
doing but that's okay
i need it i need to make a move now he
moves here i'll move back
no but benji didn't see it either
did he oh no oh oh um
back to our board we need to show this
nobody saw it
all right that was a blind spot that was
a blind spot after knight to d5 white
was threatening knight b6 attacking the
queen
and the rook so you would be winning one
of those pieces
uh danielle was annoyed by the knight on
d5 so he dropped the knight back to a
sixth attack it and benji immediately
took the bishop on e7
a strange decision but he must have had
his eyes on that bishop
priorly yeah which i don't know why he
was so eager to trade his bishop because
now daniel's actually unraveled a little
bit
he opened up the diagonal for his bishop
that bishop was kind of blocked by its
own pawns anyways so
and that knight was pretty strong in the
center to begin with
i agree with you that it's a strange
decision but
it's a time pressure yeah exactly banji
is not used to it so i think the fact
that he wants to find
quick moves is already great he's up on
time so that was
a conscious decision and maybe take take
number two if we refresh our board he
made it to d5 with his knight
he made it to d5 with his knight and now
daniel takes it
um if we just go back one move andrea i
was curious if we were gonna
you're doing amazing you're doing
amazing we didn't have a second
chance at that night for because it was
traded danielle took the knight on d5
okay and this is the current position
yes we are here right with you anna
not one step behind right here okay
we've got this we've got this guarding
on a backward spawn like you were
mentioning earlier
and that's an issue because how do you
guard that pawn the bishop is in the way
so rook 2d8
will not defend the pawn i wonder if
daniel will try to go for
some kind of a counter attack bishop g4
to try to detect the e to pawn or take
on c4
look at moves like knight b4 any
any threats or jumps that he can go for
with the knight knight to be for
he plays indeed i don't know if it's
good but it looks like it does something
yeah now i mean after this both these
pieces will be under attack he has to
trade then we have the strong rook on
d6 attacking the bishop attacking the
pawn this pawn taking because of the
bishop
i mean this position is looking pretty
good for benji
he has won the pawn and yes you're right
that now with the rook on d6 d7 bishop
hanging later the a6 pawn two could be
um in trouble as well as the e5 pawn so
it's it's more than the d6 pawn it feels
like
benji will win at least one more point
and he's up on time
there's no increment the reminder that
one minute 23 seconds is all that dania
has
if he runs out of time he loses the game
yup and now yeah benji could clearly
even though he was less experienced he
has been performing very well f6 i think
is a
good practical decision to try to mess
things up but banji reacts with bishop
c3 pointing out that the knight on b4
doesn't have too many squares knight to
c2
attacking the rook c1
c4 yeah e4 was also a threat as you were
pointing out to
cut the bishop uh from the defense of
the knight on c2 knight to a3
spotted by danny and he plays it oh my
goodness he's seen
everything that's crazy he does spot
tactical patterns very quickly benjamin
might have missed the night fork earlier
but now he sees it all he sees it all
and daniel is giving up the knight on c4
no choice yeah if he ran to b1 we still
had e4
wow he's spotting these so fast
i feel like he could have tried to go
back to c2 because at least it was gonna
attack the bishop but now this is gonna
be
a piece of a piece up for benji he can
also
take the pawn on a6 he decides rook to
d5 instead
he's up on the clock and off with a full
piece yup daniel's down to
under one minute no increments so
this thing yeah so if he takes here we
can take with a check or
we could save this bishop yes they
traded in the dark side
in a funny way wow
still an extra piece for benji and he's
capturing the pawn too
with the rook he knows that simplifying
the position is good for him because
of having an extra bishop in this
endgame upper bishop and upper pawn
it's looking very difficult for danielle
with only 33 seconds on the clock
yeah benji is a monster doing him no
counter play
keeping his pawn in the center making
another pass one here
he didn't even consider taking on f5
that would have dropped the beef
the d5 bishop he doesn't blunder and he
has
23 seconds i mean there's somebody
winning plans for white here
let's see if banji can keep up this
excellent speed and quality of moves
because he has been playing very
precisely apart from that one missed
chance of the night fork he has done a
really good job in this blitz game and
he hasn't played many blitz games we
know from his coach that this is
exactly what they prepared for i can
just imagine hammer right now just
glowing with
pride excellent choice again
to just go for creating an a passport
and push it he can't push it right now
because
he's thinking he gives the check defend
his rook now he can push
but he's also going on time he started
thinking he's down to 30 seconds and he
has to see
that he can push a6 and then run a7
a8 that will be checkmate promoting with
checkmate
yep i was gonna say maybe he was
thinking like if there was a sack on the
bishop
and they would push a7 this would be
hanging but
everybody nineteen eleven benji should
push the boat well you see he's got
checkmate
he has to push and he's got checkmate
into you but he's not like two
seconds because rook takes okay all
right yeah now let's check me ten
seconds
nine eight he didn't play in the
painting
no he's gonna i think daniel's gonna
flag that oh my god he has five seconds
seconds four just moved that's what he's
doing
oh oh my goodness
he wow i was getting so close i timed
out ben jesus
1.2 seconds moving right away
ah he deserves it anyway but i don't
know how the heck that happened
wow sick one sick one
what a game wow
clutch win by banjo fishy he had the
upper hand and he had checkmate if we
just roll back to that moment i thought
banjo was calculating that he had that
palm push
and he was one move away from checkmate
you promote
a8 and that guards the rook maybe he was
worried that the rook was hanging
he didn't push he wasn't checkmate and
then he had
one second left it was definitely
everything
sure definitely the time pressure but he
did it and i mean not having a lot of
experience and without increment
but he saved it right in time and
was such
absolute gentleman we're going to be
talking to the players in a moment this
was our second quarter finals of the day
benjamin fishy qualifying to the
semi-finals
daniel negron who won the first game but
then benji came back in the second rapid
game and won this final
sudden death blitz game we're gonna go
for a short break and then we are back
with the players boxing three presented
by grif6
he choked so bad he choked but he still
managed to win the game
the bullet training came to the rescue
and with one second remaining oh my gosh
if benji made his move in time the granu
had 0.1 seconds left
the granu if benji had failed to make
his move
would have won with .1 seconds
uh but but he made it he made it
and the crown who loses on time and
benji's through to the semi-final
oh my oh wow pickle thank you so much
for the five dollar dono
oh gosh i am very happy we practiced one
minute games
i was having so much fun when we did the
five minute games
because i thought it was so fun to to to
do
commentary on benji playing one minute
benji didn't like it
benji doesn't like being low on time it
stresses him out
but i'm very glad we practiced that
situation
coming in with the five gifted subs
thank you so much bola
also coming in with the gifted subs it's
two
to high coming in with the five gifted
oh my gosh an islumo coming in with 100
bits
bola mvp no today the mvp
is benji clutching it up in
literally the last second of the match
he comes in with the clutch
uh also oh my bad i i needed to make a
new board so my alerts haven't been
showing up
i cannot get better than that i don't
think it can
i don't think it can get better than
that
but benji let's be honest
that blitz game he nailed it he nailed
it he
played that blitz game so well
benji just he dominated from start to
finish
and he was finding all the double
attacks
yes he he almost messed it up because he
gets a low on time
he doesn't like to get low on time but
throughout that game he dominated and
overall i think he's a deserved winner
of this uh this quarterfinal
this is the most exciting chess i've
ever seen well i'm glad
you enjoyed it viper stick around for
more
exciting chess because the semi-final
might get
even better uh uh
um benji will play the winner
uh between uh rayne wilson
and um and the ludwig
so benji has qualified to the
semi-finals
and he's going to get a tough game there
as well thank you kai for the sub
thank you kai
a rain wilson or moist okay my bad
i it it's gonna be rain wilson let's be
honest
it's gonna be rain wilson in the
welcome back to the broadcast of park
chambers three presented by grip six we
are being joined by benjamin fische and
daniel negrano
benji daniel what a match this has been
yeah it was pretty close uh looking like
a bit closer than uh
especially that last game uh yeah that
one second left was that i didn't even
realize i only had one second
i'm not gonna lie i got a little bit
lucky but you know
happier happy i won by timeout i guess
daniel should have prepared the dirty
flagging techniques
at the end there taking your queen could
have tried something tricky
you know you're right actually that's
like i should have strategized for that
because
when i had two seconds left i'm like
wait a minute how am i out because i
forgot
while i was playing that there's no
increments because i was like oh don't
worry you play fast you're good so
when i was down four points with like 30
40 seconds left the
strategy should have been to just start
taking everything and trade trade trade
and then try to like you know win the
the cheesy way
win by time yeah i mean that's all
bullet chests man
it doesn't matter how bad you're losing
you hang on till the end and you try to
get any flag you can
yeah that's the way you learn lesson
learned like yeah cause like even when
you're in a losing position
uh with with the time factor especially
short for i know i don't know if benji
plays a lot of five minute games but
significant difference between 10 and
increment and five in terms of how
quickly you got to make moves
benji your coach was saying that you
don't play
much blitz chess how did you feel about
playing this tiebreaker are we going to
go back to the rapid games as well but
just
the fact that you had to play a
tiebreaker daniel i think you have quite
some experience
in blitz chess i have seen over 900
games in blitz
on your account but maybe most of them
are with increment do you prefer playing
with increment
well i think a lot of those blitz games
happen before it switched to rapid or i
don't know
because i always played 10-minute games
and i only i don't i didn't play 900
that are less than 10 for sure
i like the increment aspect because like
you know at least when you're down to a
minute you know
you're not just completely dead you know
you get that back i love the idea so
much frankly
that i want to start integrating that
into poker tournaments because i think
it would really be helpful to uh
speed things up and make it really
exciting as we had here with the the
tiebreak match that came down to one
second
too bad he didn't notice maybe he took
another second i would have won by time
crazy so close so close it was really
close benji your thoughts on that final
moment you said that you realized later
that you did have
checkmate in one and that maybe in that
case your coach wouldn't have had a
heart attack when you had only one
second left with a queen up
uh yeah i realized right after that i
when i checked with the brook that i
could have checked mate and wanted him
uh but you know i i i did realize that i
was like pretty low on time so i just
started rushing my moves
uh and if you could show that position
that moment revenge is saying
uh when he had the promotion yeah you
were very low on time
dania all credits to you by the way
though because you were
low on time and you were down a piece so
you almost made a miracle happen by
coming back
on both like you escaped with your king
when the king was gonna be checkmated
and you also managed to
to cut down on time because benji was
ahead on time for
most of the game yeah no i mean listen
he's he he's he played really really
well and you know when you're playing
with short time and you're a beginner
like me or you know at our level
like you're just going to make mistakes
when you're rushed right and that's okay
um the one that i wasn't rushed on the
big mistake was in game two
where i moved the wrong rook to block
the the queen check
and i blundered and i let him do that
what do you call that you call that the
botez gambit i just
i actually didn't see it either i saw a
five and i thought about it and
i was like why is this losing and then i
i saw at the same time you did so
yeah i didn't see it i was too
preoccupied with like you know my attack
that's one of those mistakes i'm making
chess is like
oh you get like you know one tunnel
vision in your attack and you're like
oops
you know you don't just donate the queen
and then as hannah says like it happened
to me again
after i gave away the queen i mean i
could just take his bishop and i'm like
nope
i don't want it now you keep it yeah
sometimes it happens that then you make
another mistake because you're
you're i think you were talking about it
on your stream that it happens and poker
2 when
when you get tilted for a moment and
then it can affect the next decision
too but you you thought you both fought
so well if we go
back to to this rook d4 move in game two
up until that moment we thought daniel
that you did have quite some
compensation
for the pawn because uh i feel like you
do like these type of positions where
even though your opponent can have one
or two extra pawns you have
initiative you're going with these
aggressive attacking moves
and if it wasn't for this tactical motif
let's say king to h1 or rook f2
you you have quite a lot of initiative
for the pawn and for banjo it's not easy
to develop the c8 bishop that's always
the sad piece in the
french defense unfortunately but benji
you do love your french defense and
you you came back in a situation where
you had to win
you had to win this game in order to
earn a tiebreaker
um if we also discuss some of the
details from game one by the way and
drive
if you haven't i'm here i am right here
i don't know where the bullet went but i
have this one
sure no worries daniel your thoughts on
game one the game you won and how you
felt about that bishop
winning the rook so after e5 you were
thinking of this ampersand so you did
all this on purpose and it i think it
was a great idea to free your pieces
you took back on e6 with the rook and
then benji pushed e4
i was saying to andra i think banji
wants to set up this bishop h3
tactics it's a very sneaky one it's
really sneaky
to spot it and it eventually happened
the move later
that he managed to win your rook so it
wasn't uh
spotted but you recovered so well you
recovered right after
because white is an exchange up but i
thought you came up with some really
really creative ideas moving the king
away opening up the g5 if you see
our board daniel um here with the attack
on the g5 bringing the queen to g4
it was an incredible comeback from a
moment of
of blundering your rogue blundering the
exchange and then you took the
initiative and
it's it's banji who has to be really
careful here
yeah so that that was interesting
because i did not see it as you said i
was like again tunnel visioned on that
bishop because my guy dave odyssey who's
a chess player
in edmonton who prepped me he uh he told
me that benji
often will move that bishop in front of
his king and he shouldn't
but he's willing to trade it often so i
was like trying to trade the bishops
and open up that like spot there um but
then
when i on the in the other game when i
was was i would when i was playing white
he literally gave me every single move
benji was going to make
up till like you know when the the the
exchange of the bishop for the
the the knight in that game like every
single move and he like he did all the
prep and show
me the benji loses here 56 of the time
so
when he did it i was like oh my god i
got him
right but then of course i made the
mistake you know with the rook but
i was definitely happy with being able
to sort of play
a sicilian type game with black because
i'm way more comfortable with that
he doesn't let me go up the right side
and just do my thing but i was able to
still
develop the position i learned an indian
just in case he moved d4
i was gonna do that so that's why i
moved the the knight first i did a lot
of new things that i don't typically do
and i learned so much with this whole
process about how chess works and
how the bluffing aspect there's so much
bluffing because like
a guy's gonna like oh you think i'm
gonna do this and then i come up with
this totally new open you've never seen
i was gonna use the ponziani if need be
because i had that in my pocket i was
gonna throw that one out later but i
didn't practice it enough
besides he plays the french anyway and
uh
yeah i mean it's been a great process
i'm you know proud of you benji you
played
really really well and i wish you luck
in the next round
thank you i have one more question for
daniel i thought of this
so do you like gambits because you like
gambling
a little bit right i like gambits
because i listen i like fun unique
different things
what i've learned you know unfortunately
is prepping gambits for a tournament is
a bad idea
because when a player knows they're
going to be playing against you all the
data well i didn't realize because one
of the things that poker players are
good at is
parsing data all the data available on
chess.com like my guy
dove in with using the explorer figuring
out all of benji's plays right
like i said i was like shocked he's like
you're gonna get this exact position
and benji loses from here and i'm like
how this is so cool
so i love that aspect of it but i've
learned to sort of like
retire the gambits again in tournaments
for
for the time being and you know use them
when i play recreational because like
when i learned the england gambit from
uh from uh
lee levi or levy sorry you know it
worked on everybody i was like beating
everyone
unfortunately when pokemony prepared for
it it just
you know you just eat dust it's like
it's no good so um
gotta learn how to play chess properly
and play the gambits for fun
tournament situation certainly but you
you came very well prepared for today so
dania you have a better coach than levy
or me or hikaru
you have definitely prepared very well
and benji kudos to you
for how far you have come you are moving
on to the semi-finals
what do you think will happen in the
other clash you will play
either against rayne wilson or against
moyes critical your thoughts on that
quarterfinal match
uh i'm i think i'm gonna be fine for i
think i'm just gonna
keep practicing you know do do the usual
keep what keep
doing what i've been doing practicing
with hammer um and i think
i think hopefully i'll be all right and
i'll be able to get to the finals
yeah i mean you and hammer dream team
man because i didn't was saying i was
coach
did that strategy but i bet hammer was
doing the same thing because i've seen
him prepared
yeah they were one step ahead of you
daniel well actually i thought i was
doing good after the opening
it's just that he's better he was he was
better after that like you know i
thought i got good positions so
yeah i certainly agree absolutely i
thought the preparation was great on
both sides
we were saying with android it felt like
we were watching a high high level chess
grand monster games because you were
blitzing at theory until move 10 and
very very classical setups from
both sides especially that french
defense game felt like
you're you're professional chess players
not professional poker and
fortnite players in this case
daniel absolutely daniel we hope to see
you be back at pogchamps 4 because
you're
more than ready to take on these
challenges so we hope to see you at the
future chess event as well
i love the process like i said i put a
lot of time into it unfortunately
wasn't good enough in the end but i was
ultimately i was proud of how i played
today
i was really disappointed how i played
against xqc i was just my brain was not
working that day
but today i thought i played as well as
i could for my level and uh i hope to be
back for pogchamps 4.
amazing that would be amazing to see and
we will be
rooting for benji now that he's moving
on to the semifinals thank you so much
for joining us and all the best for the
rest benji
thank you guys very much
that has been it benji fishy moving on
to the semi-finals and he will be
facing either rain wilson or moist
critical andra your thoughts on that
quarterfinal because benji was very
diplomatic he didn't pick
yeah well he said he was pretty
confident but rain
if it is i i my guess is gonna be rain
versus benji
and i'm terrified of rain that man is so
strong i must say
so that'll be a great matchup i think
in that case i'm going to pick charlie
because he has been preparing with
dania with daniel he's got the support
of his dog as well who often times jumps
in
through the game so that's gonna be
certainly
a tough one and we will know it soon
because tomorrow
that clash will be the first one to
start the broadcast
rayne wilson versus moyes critical take
a look at the times ladies and gentlemen
because we're going to have
four matches starting at 10 30 pacific
rain wilson against moist critical then
nico versus rubius
my heart will be absolutely torn as
usual when my students are facing each
other but they are
the quarterfinals clash in the
consolation bracket championship break
it down
between ludwig and logic one of them
will move on to the semi-finals the
other one will have to say goodbye to
the event
unfortunately as it is in knockout and
the final match will be
between pokeman and myth
they know each other very well but i
think this is gonna be the first time
they face each other at
chess that is very true they've never
played other games but
there are so many matchups tomorrow big
decisions i mean
you lose the championship you're out so
we'll see who's gonna make it
it's gonna be a very exciting day andrea
thank you so much for handling so well
the tech part
you were you were the producer of the
show it came to the board and you did
very good very good job for your first
time yeah i'm so glad everyone knows
that all the times the board was lagging
it was me
you did amazing if it was me i would
have been loading all sorts of other
browsers clicking here and there so you
did a lot better than what my boomer
skills
are capable of but we want to thank
andrea
for being here papa botez for rooting
for
for daniel now we know canadian romanian
yes
thank you anna for for carrying and yeah
the tech part
we'll get better at that you know with
as with the years to come
we hopefully have years to come for park
champs as well because this is a
brilliant
event and a reminder that we will be
back tomorrow maybe not us but the show
will be back tomorrow thank you so much
for tuning in thank you so much for
watching better
tech more smooth boards chat don't you
worry
maybe smoother boards but not smoother
brains because you guys have done an
amazing job
in the chat with all sorts of ideas and
strategies coming up always for the
players thank you so much
for following the show remember that you
can still donate every single day we
are fundraising for the 16 charities
that the participants have chosen so the
banner is below
the video you can also use exclamation
mark donating the chat click on the link
and donate chess.com we'll be matching
your donations up to a hundred thousand
dollars so make sure to
let shares of campaign loads for charity
because it's a great cause
16 charities that will be benefiting
from them and on that note
andrea final words final sign off
um i don't have any final words
very bad on the spot except that
tomorrow's gonna be a very exciting day
we got four big matches
lots of students that i'm rooting for so
how about you
thank you for being here and germany
definitely
need more bonus gambits in our lives and
our tax kits will improve one day thank
you so much again everybody
[Music]
now
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
all the way all the way down
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this
[Music]
you